peu
[Musique]
au combat bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde en parle avec nous ce soir
l'omc ait jamais de vous julien clerc
les oliviers gecina marrons chauds
la xbox d'euros ainsi michel polac
forcément les rouges du cameraman
français disparu en irak
la fonte
je la peste
facile de coqs et plus ils barjots
plus notre 20e blind test ce soir en
mondovision mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
avant de recevoir mon premier invité je
vous propose de regarder avec moi les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde a parlé et
s'est préparé par monsieur jean noël
manille tandis hertz danse connu
il va faire des photos assez jolie salle
albert et on vend ses appareils il faut
quand même déjà place l'année dernière
vous aviez fait des photos d'ailleurs
votre appareil avait été vendu
extrêmement cher ouais ouais y avait
quoi sur ces photos j'avais laurent ce
que vous avez de plus sexy en vous tous
ces noms oui tout c'est vraiment un
tournant
le film vous jouez que vous préférez
sophie en fait la vérité en vérité je
n'aime pas trop me voir dans les films
que j'ai faits devant moi aussi j'aime
pas trop te vois alors donc jacques
chirac a reçu tous les acteurs tous les
réalisateurs qui sont à cannes voilà
qu'est ce qui vous a dit il mais il m'a
dit il m'a dit mais je vous connais bien
vous avez une notoriété qui est bien
assise et moi je dis mais vous savez
monsieur dans ce métier les chaises sont
plutôt bancale et il m'a répondu oh
rassurez-vous pas tant que dans le mien
non c'est vrai pour rapho voulaient
interviewer le soir quand il rentre à la
maison parce que bernard bonsoir
comment pourriez-vous nous décrire la
journée qui vient de se dérouler et puis
bernard pour qu'il pût expliqué à nos
amis qui nous regardent
pourquoi vous n'avez pas appeler à 15
heures comme prévu berna il est venu
comme jean-jacques servan-schreiber et
sabine de fouquières reçoivent des
lettres anonymes antisémites avec marc
et ils vous épouse pour avoir des
enfants mais des ja c'est juif sur terre
enfin des lettres extrêmement
extrêmement violente et on s'aperçoit
que c'est elle qui les écrit ça c'est
une vraie révélation
mais vous savez c'est une histoire que
beaucoup de proches de françoise giroud
connaissait depuis depuis très longtemps
quelle question devrait je vous posais
pour vous faire rougir mes mensurations
enfin un truc comme ça vous avez des
gros nichons
quelle question devrait je vous posais
pour terminer cette interview en beauté
christine quand est-ce qu'on se voie à
ces géniales ce que vous faites pour la
croix rouge
moi ça et c'est avec plaisir vraiment à
tout ce qui me demandent la croix rouge
je suis prête à prête à faire oui le
bouche à bouche est tout ouïe des
raisons sanitaires évidemment bien sûr
c'est bien ça ne serait pas trop il est
pas mais pour animer la personne on met
pas la langue
dites-moi ce que c'est le coup du
chapeau le hat trick qua non non c'est
pas parce que non c'est quand ils
marquent trois buts dans le même match
sas a permis à une question n'est pas
habitué c'est pas un triplé
sous le capot c'est quoi alors rihanna
sait quoi d'avoir la barre transversale
sarkozy
vous dites la retraite c'est s'asseoir
et attendre la mort de pas près de
prendre votre retraite donc certainement
si on parle beaucoup de retraite en
france à ce moment puisque pas non mais
jamais qu'il faut il faut continuer à
rester vivant dans l'esprit pour que le
corps est jeune lui aussi est ce que
vous trouvez normal que le plus grand
rappeur du monde
eminem soit blanc le plus grand rappeur
du monde et plan le meilleur golfeur et
les soeurs williams tennis tennis woman
show au noir est aussi le plus grand
basketteur et chinois ce sont les
suisses pour l'america's cup et
l'allemagne ne peut pas traquer
c'était
déclare me
jack et nathan lendemain fille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci comment ça va alors ça va très
bien et toi très bien à part ça j'ai vu
le programme
ouais c'est une au programme ce soir
énorme mais si oui c'est mieux que la
semaine dernière y avait personne la
semaine
ça t'a plu et c'est une mission la
semaine dernière qu'ils étaient bien
ainsi ainsi sophie marceau sophie
marceau celle de la ville me dit quelque
chose je suis apte ou non
jamel debbouze tu vois qu'il s'est tu
vois pas mais si jamel debbouze
[Applaudissements]
j'arrête je comprend un petit peu ses
applaudissements et cet accueil par ce
que j'ai lu cette semaine dans le figaro
entreprises que vous étiez l'acteur le
mieux payé de france devant gérard
depardieu je les lui aussi j'étais très
déçu par ce qui a été
ce qui a été marqué parce que c'est
complètement faux j'ai touché le triple
ça va venir
que ce soit par l'ess qui m'a amusé le
plus c'est la manière dont ça a été
présenté son journal de france 2 ce
qu'il disait à la grande surprise
générale oui bien sûr vous revenez en
deux parties non ouais
oui c'est ça être j'ai trouvé ça j'ai
trouvé ça amusant ça nous fait plus de
deux millions d'euros c'est beaucoup
c'est vrai
non
par jour tu avais combien de jours de
tournage même quand j'avais aucun
problème quand je touchais 3700 francs
contre emploi solidarité
j'ai aucun problème à toucher autant
tout va bien autant d'argent aujourd'hui
comment situer leurs emails et sms sans
problème je le répète c'est super mais
jamel en plus ça part vite l'argent et
j'en ai plus j'en ai plus là parce que
mon frère mon mot à ma cousine
d'audincourt mon frère de casa et voici
le discours de gérard philipe ya plus
personne
je reste combien sur les 2 millions là
bas il doit me rester 700 euros ça va
vite en tout et pour tout ça va vite et
par les impôts t'as rien non non ça
c'est pas que je me suis arrangée avec
énormément je les perds est sûre si
cette tige dr djamel alors vous venez de
cannes là où vous êtes une star absolue
d'ailleurs j'ai vu dans paris match que
vous étiez avec les plus grandes stars
du festival qui apprécie beaucoup votre
le pas vrai j'étais amie de la weed
je tiens avec j'y tiens lexar la gt1
avec cai abdel kader aoun
j'étais avec qu'il y avait d'autres ont
éjecté qu'avec des cailleras du 7-8
c'est le seul ce largage connaître
[Applaudissements]
c'est alors un parc à loups passé
beaucoup de temps au maroc beaucoup de
temps à marrakech vous avez une maison
jamel et où vous avez monté des studios
de cinéma
ouais ouais on les a pas encore cela
fait remonter puisqu'on n'a pas encore
on est pas encore arrivé dans la phase
où les studios sont en construction mais
on y arrive on y arrive très vite et
j'espère le charles 1 que dc dc prochain
festival du cinéma à marrakech on puisse
poser la première pierre
ouais ouais j'ai été super centre et en
tournant intérêts que ceux de voir que
j'avais je n'avais pas d'à priori mais
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que les
marocains connaissent aussi bien le
cinéma j'étais vraiment surpris et
edward un premier assistant parlait
quatre langues différentes j'irai 4000
personnes
je me suis dit mais j'ai rarement vu ça
mais qui parle français anglais arabe
dans la même phrase ça donne
si j'ai besoin que peuvent-ils sais rien
mais mais mais mais mais samassa massama
je me suis aperçu je le savais déjà mois
mais le maroc s'est pas car c'est pas
qu'une terre sera qu'un paysage c'est
aussi des gens tu vois ce que dirait
qu'ils connaissent bien leur caf donc ça
me paraissait évident et logique de
montée des studios c'est une façon en
plus de faire du business et d'aider les
gens qui vivent là bas c'est vraiment
pas pour faire du business de ce qu'un
studio finalement ça rapporte pas tant
d'argent que ça ça sent tout d'abord
beaucoup au départ mais moi ma démarche
première c'est vraiment d'essayer
d'amener de faire en sorte que les gens
de mon pays puisse travailler dans les
conditions les mieux possible les plus
normal puisque on monte d'abord avant
l'entrée des studios un centre national
de l'audiovisuel
ah ouais pour former les gens aux
premiers métiers du cinéma et et la
démarche allait purement professionnel
d'après avant d'être financière c'est
bien moi j'essaye jamais de vos jeunes
au maroc à casablanca le vendredi 16 mai
cinq attentats suicide ont fait 48
victimes majorité de marocains plus
trois français deux espagnols un italien
pour en parler avec nous j'appelle
samira sitail
samira bonsoir donc vous êtes directrice
de l'information de la chaîne marocaine
2m
merci d'être avec nous djamel au maroc
j'imagine que c'est une star comme en
france qua non ah oui mais aussi connu
et même beaucoup plus connus
je pense europe qu'ici puisque jamais
c'est la réussite jamais c'est un
symbole jamel c'est pas uniquement la
banlieue qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il soit
salué voir décrit aussi par d'autres
parce qu'ils touchent le plus beau
salaire de chambre si jamais l'état
social au maroc gmail s'est fait à la
fois et c'est une mégastar bigot ce
corps de ferme ta gueule maintenant j'ai
amené mon avocat et que donc en plein
milieu des festivités organisées à
l'occasion de la naissance le leem et du
premier fils de mohammed vi le roi du
maroc et deux jours après l'aïd al
mawlid la fête de la naissance du
prophète
cinq attentats à la bombe ou la voiture
piégée visant essentiellement des
restaurants des hôtels fréquentés par
des étrangers ou lié à la communauté
juive ont eu lieu à casablanca
li membre des commandos kamikaze était
d'origine marocaine et ferait partie
d'un groupe islamiste appelait le droit
chemin
implanté dans la banlieue de casablanca
est rattachée plus ou moins à al qaïda
alors vous qui êtes directrice
d'information de l'important de chaînes
marocaines
que savez vous sur les coupables de
cette opération
avant ils sont tous marocains ce n'est
pas uniquement les huit en fait on a
identifié au jour d'aujourd'hui huit
cadavres sur les treize kamikazes qui se
sont donné la mort sur les différents
sites que vous avez décrit jeudi rossi
oui on a visé les symboles
on a visé des symboles qui font
qu'aujourd'hui le maroc est l'antithèse
la plus complète de ce que les radicaux
les intégristes défendent comme modèle
de société
nous leur faisons tous les jours la
démonstration de ce que le maroc peut
être un pays musulman profondément
attaché à ses racines profondément
musulman tout en mettant un pays arabe
berbère juifs
d'une certaine manière puisque cette
religion fait partie de l'histoire du
maroc
donc ces marocains qui sont touchés
lorsqu'on pose une bombe devant
l'alliance juive c'est les marocains qui
sont touchés c'est pas les juifs les
musulmans c'est d'abord cela est un juif
persécuté dans ce pays c'est quelque
chose de nouveau c'est quelque chose de
nouveau pour nous comme le sont ces
attentats imaginez qu'une ville paisible
se réveille un matin dans l'horreur la
plus absolue avec j'ai pas une ré cela
aux téléspectateurs mais c'est vraiment
le loreur et moi j'ai eu un fils mais
tout ça j'ai eu à voir tout cela mais
j'ai eu à faire des choix de ne pas
montrer le visage une tête un gamin qui
dort encore qui va s'éveiller avec les
images
peut-être de son père la tête coupée à
la une de notre journal j'ai refusé cela
j'ai voulu respecter cela et je crois
que tous les marocains quelque part sont
un peu comme moi aujourd'hui ils ont
cette attitude à la fois de surprise à
la fois de révolte de colère et en même
temps et c'est ça peut-être si j'osais
dire à toute chose malheur est bon que
nous retiendrons de ce 16 mai qui était
le jour de mon anniversaire
nous retiendrons que nous sommes plus
forts et que notre modèle est le bon et
aussi que cette guerre antiterroriste
menée à l'échelle mondiale dans un
désordre absolu depuis 18 mois nous en
payons nous les marocains aujourd'hui
les pots cassés et que c'est un échec
absolu
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est important de dire c'est que
ça arrive au moment où ou maroc
progresse vers une vraie démocratie où
l'on commença à s'inscrire vers le ce
qui m'a le plus étonné c'est que
vraiment c'est c
j'ai le sentiment que mon pays mon pays
a été touché au coeur et et et en
traître presque parce que j'ai j'ai
j'avais le sentiment que mon pays
progressaient que ça accès que ça que ça
se développait qu'on allait way qu'on
allait vers une vraie ouverture sais pas
comment l'expliquer mais j'ai été j'ai
été outré mon papa parce que j'ai jamais
connu ça au maroc j'ai jamais vu ma mère
dans cet état là jamais vu mon grand
père m'a jamais ma famille dans ces cas
là et je me suis aperçu que partout dans
le monde
aujourd'hui on est on est on est plus à
l'abri nulle part il ya vu me voir sont
les routes
il ya ça a été touché new york a été
touché en plein coeur paris pareil à
vitrolles ya catherine mégret
on est à l'abri nulle part donc
franchement aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment qu'il faut continuer à vivre
sa vie comme on l'entend et comme on dit
dans ma cité knicks à mr le maire
[Applaudissements]
enfin il faut quand même espérer que
c'est pas à ces événements dramatiques
ils vont faire changer le maroc est bien
au contraire vous savez nous sommes à la
veille d'une très grosse manifestation
dans les rues de gaza
tout le monde descend demain tout le
maroc est dehors
demain suif musulmans chrétiens vivant
dans ce pays puisque on en parle et
qu'il s'agit bien de cela nous défendons
cela c'est une partie de notre identité
nous combattrons l'intégrisme et si nous
n'étions pas conscient depuis un an
parce que c'est vrai on nous a dit il ya
des cellules dormantes
attention quand on a parlé sa mue avec
son appareil des cellules dormantes
il ya beaucoup d'intellectuels et
certains journaux qu'on dit c'est une
manoeuvre du pouvoir en fait c'est
existe pas tout ça c'est pour aller vers
le plus sécuritaire et en fait c'était
vrai c'était vrai et depuis le 16 mai je
peux vous garantir que cette presse là
où ces intellectuels là où ces gauchos
caviar qui hante la capitale économique
et rabat et qui ne finalement ne
connaissent pas très bien le maroc et
bien je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
sont très mal à l'aise et qu'aujourd'hui
s'agit pour nous de protéger ce que nous
sommes c'est notre patrimoine c'est ce
que nous sommes et le marché le plus
important ça l'est pour le maroc c'est
la france 55 % du flux touristique au
maroc c'est le marché français et au
contraire et c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire et c'est pour ça que je
suis heureuse d'être là en france et sur
ce plateau de télévision
parce que les français ont dit non avec
les marocains à ce terrorisme en dix ans
20 nouveaux noms réservations dans les
maintient le maroc le maroc c'est aussi
un peu chez nous voilà
elvis versa on avait compris les
réactions mohamed 6 s'est rendu
évidemment sur les lieux du drame
alors moi métier c'est le commandeur des
croyants ça veut dire qu il est
commandeur de tous les croyants c'est à
dire les juifs les chrétiens et les
musulmans
les trois religions les trois religions
il est bien sûr musulman est la religion
majoritaire au maroc et nie slam mais il
est le protecteur comme le fut
d'ailleurs son grand-père et sa la
communauté juive séfarade le sait et
j'aurais tant aimé l'ont acclamé de la
cantine et vu le gouvernement du chili a
dit au roi mohamed 5 vous nous livrer
les juifs pour qu'ils puissent livrer
aux allemands il a dit je ne voulais
livrerait pas ce qu'ils sont sous ma
protection lorsque d'espagne on les a
chassés réprimer ils sont venus au maroc
ils vivent et je répète je ne sais pas
si je les exprime bien nous sommes
habitués bien comprend entre le fait est
que c'est ça qu'on veut toucher et ce
n'est pas uniquement de le défendre nous
du maroc nous pays arabe musulman
revendiquant cette identité musulmane
tout en nous projetant ne comme
n'importe quel citoyen de ce monde
aujourd'hui
alors mohamed 6 7 en train de
démocratiser le maroc mais effectivement
plus de liberté c'est plus de liberté
pour les idées toutes les idées même les
idées islamistes c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui au maroc et des journaux
quand même très radicaux qui paraissent
aujourd'hui et depuis le 16 mai les
marocains je crois qu'ils se sont rendus
compte que c'était tous pareils que
c'est les moyens qui change
il ya ceux qui prônent la violence et
ceux qui prônent cette autre violence
encore plus terrible et meurtrière à la
une de leurs fourneaux pour les
marocains c'est tous pareils il faut les
combattre et nous les combattrons et ça
ne passera pas quelle était la réaction
du parti de la justice et du
développement qui est un parti islamique
qui est reconnue et qui participe
la vie démocratique du maroc bien sûr
qu'ils les ont témoin qui les ont
condamnés mais lorsque leurs
responsables elle a une de sept présents
vous parliez tout à l'heure
font l'apologie de ces groupuscules
radicaux qui aujourd'hui agissent sur le
terrain ils sont aussi responsables que
c'est treize kamikazes qui sont
marocains des jeunes qui se sont fait
encadrer et manipulés par des personnes
qui auraient pu être celle du pjd
mais le pjd a condamné les attentats et
pourquoi leur intervention n'a pas été
retransmise à la télévision marocaine
sur tvm je ne suis pas la tvm je suis
deuxième look chaîne de télévision mais
le fait est que vous n'allez pas dans un
moment comme celui-ci où les partis
politiques progressistes de ce pays et
sont nombreux les rejettent leur dise
non faites votre manif tout seul on ne
fera pas avec vous on fera la mode de
notre côté bon il est tout à fait la
réaction est tout à fait normal et moi
je le dis et je le revendique
je refuse comme ça a été le cas moi ça
tombe responsable de la presse française
un moment donné qu'ils ont décidé
officieusement de banaliser leurs
discours leurs appels au meurtre
ce n'est pas cela la démocratie ce n'est
pas cela le maroc que moi je voudrais
que vous proposez finalement c'est qu'on
considère au maroc le pjd comme en
france le front national est considéré
c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas admis en
fait dans le jeu médiatique
votre comparaison est un peu caricatural
mais je vous dirais une chose elle me
convient tout à fait et je crois que si
vous posez la question de savoir
pourquoi tout d'un coup ils ont 38
députés au parlement je vous dirais
qu'on n'a pas vu venir la vague qui a
été celle de le pen
l'année dernière mais je passerai sur
les détails je dirais que la comparaison
n'est pas malvenu johns avait des
copains qui sont tentés par l'islamisme
maroc ou en français malheureusement
malheureusement dans le quartier souvent
les mecs de mon quartier sont pas
respectés et un terroriste c'est quoi
enfin j'ai pas la définition mais je
pense que c'est d'abord un frustré c'est
bien qu'on n'est pas contents qu'on
rejette quelqu'un qu'on méprise et ça
doit être profondément meurtrie je crois
pouvoir en arriver là et je sais que ça
t'amène de mon quartier non facilement
se faire embrigader et se retrouve dans
des histoires bizarres parce qu'on n'est
calcule pas mais si on les écoute pas
parce qu'on a on les rejette en bloc et
si j'ai réussi à m'en sortir aujourd'hui
sans prendre c'est parce qu'on pense
parce qu'à un moment donné on m'a dit tu
es un mec bien quand tu me fonce et et
c'est devant ce discours là que j'ai eu
envie de faire mieux est d'en faire un
et deux et d'essayer de mieux que je
peux de décevoir personne
mais c'est sûr que que nous en tout cas
dans leurs bottes dans le banlieue comme
comme je le répète souvent lyon en en
zone d'éducation prioritaire si on est
en zone d'urbanisation priorité quand on
est quand on monte des commerces et en
zone franche qu'à la fin les appels des
zonards
je vous dirais c'est difficile et c'est
sûr que quand on trouve le réconfort
dans une mosquée enfin moi je ne
comprends pas mais je les jeunes
explique en tout cas cessé ses démos qui
est de voir un mec qui dit tu es un mec
bien continue lâche pas pendant qu'elle
devait le dit dans quel secteur
d'activité dévolu ça fait c'est toujours
ça fait toujours plaisir
c'est vrai qu'au maroc le succès des
islamistes radicaux c'est plus que leurs
prêches encore c'est la façon qu'ils ont
de s'occuper des gens ses accents soul
terrain ils ont des actions de
solidarité des actions caritatives
il ya que le pjd cas un vrai projet de
société on se demande si les autres
partis politiques qui sont en danger
démocratique au maroc ont des projets de
société aussi défini que pjd ça c'est
faux c'est faux thierry ces fossés
véhicule est effectivement par un
syndrome de publications celles dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure il y en a
plusieurs y en a deux ou trois et c'est
aussi ce que les médias occidentaux
souhaitent retenir
vous le savez très bien on ne parle
jamais des trains qui arrivent à l'heure
on ne parle que de ceux qui sont en
retard c'est une très belle et samira
lâche pas le morceau tout le tien le pjd
est un train qui malheureusement
arrivent en retard
bientôt on tente d'en juger noël un
autre juste juste à temps ouais
carrément sahel non attendez la nature
mais non c'est à elle de parler mais non
j'ai pas mentir l'elysée
joachim sauer la laisser tranquille il
ne faut pas l'énerver
mais c'est vrai enfin ils n'ont pas de
projet de société ils n'ont pas de
revendications ils n'ont pas de message
vous savez il joue un peu sur cette
fibre arabo-musulmane attention et nous
les arabes les d'identité etc
il joue sur cette fibre mais en profite
très franchement pour mon pays c'est la
première phase pour ça que j'étais
choqué je vous ai dit oui en début
d'émission que ça m'avait c'est bien ça
fait mal au coeur de voir cet état là
mais mais mais c'est bien sûr que c'est
grave mais encore une fois plus personne
n'est à l'abri donc on en parle
aujourd'hui moi vraiment sur le coup
j'étais très choquée et puis finalement
je me suis dit c'est la vie je vais pas
m'arrêter de vivre pour je vais pas
m'arrêter de continuer à aa les noms
n'est pas que c'est cesser si le début
pour moi presque
ouais je n'en ai pas qu'ils n'ont pas de
la résistance c'est le début de l'ajout
et tu peux plus ça quand tu veux même
essaimé ces c'est le début si le début
parce que aujourd'hui je crois en mon
pays c'est un pays envoie quelqu'un qui
est plein de promesses
sajjad bhutta kg le marque full par
exemple et comment ça déchire otages et
leur foi je fais ça rate mon premier
voyage à l'étranger est au maroc quand
j'avais 16 ans
trop coûteux et incolore alors
franchement si vous vous privez tajine
mort foule puis sarah à cause de
terroristes secteur
tout secousse marocain et couscous
tunisien alors là il ya du poisson là
mais tu vois juste la viande venue pour
éviter de 2 il s'est passé il ya pas
longtemps il faut ce terrible en algérie
et un tremblement de terre ça a fait 500
morts des milliers de blessés
elle n'a pas de pot bordel de merde
c'est ça qui est en train de me dire on
n'a pas de pot et puis moi j'ai envie
d'adresser un message d'espoir à tous
ces algériens à tous ces marocains qui
souffrent à puce et musulmans ils nous
regardent
j'espère garder au maghreb qui qui qui
qui qui sont qui sont dans le dos noir
il faut une il ya un truc qu'on se dit
waouh c'est cécile à albi là tu sais
enfin à la fin de chaque phrase est
modulaire tout va bien et j'ai envie de
leur dire du lien on est encore là où on
l'attend
[Applaudissements]
nous arrêterons pas c'est pas possible
un joli quand on termine en disant un
mot au sujet du roi du maroc qui
regardent souvent tout le monde en parle
est ce que est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va tenir bon face à sa juste peut-être
dire que quand on dit modery radical
machette et terra le roi commandeur des
croyants etc
il n'est pas le représentant d'un islam
modéré
il est le représentant de l'islam du
coup le ceux qui connaissent les livres
qui connaissent le courant et je vous
invite à le faire si vous ne connaissez
pas ce n'est pas cette haine qui se
déversent tous les jours en ce moment
c'est cesser de l'amour c'est de la
tolérance c'est beaucoup de vérités
qu'on rende qu'on donnerait les
attentats bien sûr bien sûr
alors lorsqu'on en brigade ces pauvres
dames 1 et que l'on dit vas-y tu ira au
paradis
eh bien on leur ment on leur dit que
même les femmes qui les attend et là ça
quand même
en même temps un vois moi franchement je
croyais vraiment le terroriste les
femmes c'est pas mal on a fait quelques
mines merci
info
en fait
dans le mille
aïe
exceptionnel
alors on a au maroc une femme peut être
directrice de l'information d'une chaîne
de télévision
ouais elle tout ce que ça implique au
maroc et c'est pas anodin tu vois c'est
une meuf que j'adore ella ella ella
beaucoup de courage et beaucoup de
charisme
ouais ça ira si tu m'écoutes skiff
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
[Musique]
voici julien acteurs
j'adore bonsoir
julien clerc bonsoir alors avant toute
chose sophie marceau et était là la
semaine dernière elle vous en veut plus
du tout elle a dit que c'était de
l'histoire ancienne que cette histoire
là tu voulais parce qu'il a fait une
chanson sur ses nichons pas contente en
fait évidemment tu me connais quand elle
est venue ici la semaine dernière j'en
ai parlé
imaginons ce pas un problème et qu'il a
été mais chose qu'une chose et tout au
contraire j'étais admiratif mais bon je
suis l'histoire en a mal pris à l'époque
donc est ce qui s'était passé je viens à
l'époque elle avait mal pris elle s'est
déjà moi quand j'avais vu arriver le
texte de david avec le titre
l'esa de sophie marceau je le suis on
est mal barré mais en même temps quand
j'ai mais je sais c'est une chanson sur
les sur tout ce qui fait mal sur ce
qu'ils piquent ski koba ce qui est sûr
les armes et on échange en face de ça on
disait il faut des ronds fond des choses
qui soient ronde et à chaque fois la
suite c'était et les sainte sophie
marceau moi je trouvais ça mignon
et puis ma foi bon mais tant mieux si
c'est oublié j'ai vraiment vraiment elle
était tout à fait cool il n'y a plus de
souci il ya plus aucun problème avec
sophie marceau
ça va prendre avec sophie marceau toi je
m'apercevais ni à l'école ni avec six
ans pour ma part
pour moi j'aime beaucoup julien j'en
profite c'est pour ça que je restais
pour te dire que que j'avais jamais qui
est touché par le fait que tu viens de
me voir jouer sur scène j'avais perdu
les moyens sont là je me rappelle je te
jure je savais que c'était dans la salle
il y avait alors tu vois tu arrivais
plus à jouer non c'est pas ça c'est que
c'est que ça m'arrive rarement je te
jure mais quand il ya des gens que que
je respecte et que j'aime bien je je je
je le sais donc c'est pas si évident moi
je voulais juste que ça maintenant je
vais boire et julien j'ai beaucoup de
restaurateurs partagent pas la chanson
non
merci aux plaisirs
bien julien alors les problèmes donc
avec les seins de sophie marceau
ça risque pas d'arriver avec votre
nouvel album qui sort chez virgin et qui
s'appelle studio
[Musique]
je me suis gouré
voilà ça s'appelle studio et c'est une
surprise puisque vous reprenez julien
clerc dans cet album des grands
standards américains joués par les plus
grands jazzmen du moment et avec des
paroles françaises écrit par les plus
grandes stars de la chanson voilà c'est
pas gentil parce que là il est prêt ce
bar est quand même pas ce que je voulais
dire simplement c'est que malgré tout ça
standards américains paroles françaises
on dirait du julien clerc le single
s'appelle avant qu'on aille au fond des
choses
je serai juste
si je peux
aulas
chaud
[Musique]
demande
pour une
julien clerc avant copenhague c'est le
premier
extrait de sang mais madame
qu'ils s'appellent studio voilà alors
j'y viens on va prendre les choses par
le par le commencement
les parents de julien était déjà pas
d'accord sur son prénom et tu veux dire
que sam son père voulait qu'il s'appelle
paul et sa mère voulait qu'il s'appelle
alain donc il s'est appelé paul alain
paul alain leclerc alors d'ailleurs vos
parents n'étaient pas d'accord sur votre
prénom est très peu de temps après votre
naissance ils ont divorcé de vie quel
âge un an et demi un an et demi oui
alors ensuite votre vie julien est
divisé en deux d'un côté yahia votre
père haut fonctionnaire à l'unesco
vous passez la semaine avec lui à
bourg-la-reine dans une maison en
meulière et là c'est une musique
classique 1 c'est votre belle-mère donc
vous fait écouter de la musique la cima
mise au point qui m'a guardian aussi
voilà ça c'est toute la semaine et le
week-end julien le petit julien est avec
sa mère alors votre maire c'est la
branche antillaise de la famille c'est
une femme seule secrétaire de direction
qui laisse dites vous des traces de
rouge à lèvres sur les filtres des
cigarettes se décrit le personnage c'est
une idée de romancier ça voilà et donc
chez votre mère contrairement à ce qui
se passe chez votre père il ya la télé
il ya des disques il ya des disques de
brassens il ya des disques de jazz et
c'est comme ça en fait que vous
rencontrez le jazz à cette époque là il
a le premier disque auquel vous
intéresser c'est un indice de nat king
cole qui s'appelle dream a little dream
of milk était repris d'ailleurs depuis
maintes fois vous écoutez aussi sidney
bechet et puis d'autres pianistes de
jazz qui par exemple cinéma louis
armstrong et puis alors après par
exemple j'écoutais beaucoup m'acheter
des dix d'art tatum avec bastia beaucoup
de pianiste un peu plus tard bobby
timmons thelonious monk un peu à part un
peu après richard toujours des pianistes
est le premier artiste que vous verrez
sur scène c'est duke ellington à
l'olympia et puis ensuite l'arrivée des
beatles et à ce moment là vous éloigner
du jazz parce que le jazz devient
compliqué devient une musique de
spécialistes vous êtes emportés par par
la vague de la pop british mon pied
voilà après vous oubliez un peu le jazz
en non pas vraiment parce que les
artistes que j'ai toujours aimé c'était
quand même toujours des descendants du
jazz the doors ray charles marvin gaye
toute la soul music tous les artistes
que j'aimais beaucoup de noirs
américains venaient tous de la civi
mondher a fait ses premières armes là
dedans alors ses chansons de jazz et ses
tubes ses standards des années 30 40 50
continue à vous hanter toute votre vie
et chaque fois que vous en entendez un
vous avez une espèce de coup au coeur de
la vie des champions
c'est ce qu'elle saku d'harmonie aussi
c'est désarmant les accords la monique
mais c'est une musique que je connais
pas que mon oreille et mon coeur adore
mais je ne sais pas faire
et donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
que c'est comme un truc qu'il faut
exorciser
alors voila mais lesquels chanter un
jour votre ami et néanmoins agent
bertrand de labbey vous dit il ya 80 de
celles qui ont été chantées par sinatra
donc d'un seul coup ça permet quand même
de classifier les choses oui parce que
sinon trahies les tâches entendeur cas
si la touchante et voilà mais c'est pas
toujours ses versions à lui que j'ai
préféré vous avez vous écouté les
versions de sinatra mais vous écoutez
aussi celle de la fitzgerald louis
amstrong de nat king cole de diana krall
et même de rochechouart entraînante
récemment mais qui a fait un disque un
peu comme bryan ferry d'ailleurs aussi
un disque de reprises de grands
standards de l'époque
donc voila et à un moment où j'arrivais
avec un tracklisting c'est à dire est qu
une liste de chansons et là vous voulez
réapproprier c'est à dire que voulait
jouer jusqu'à ce qu'elle devienne près
du mans de julien clerc
c'est en ce sens en ceci que c'est pas
un disque de reprises c'est plutôt un
disque en fit dire de revisitation c'est
à dire de mettre des paroles françaises
sur ces grandes musiques éternelle voilà
alors les auteurs c'est maxime le
forestier c'est david mcneil c'est jean
loup dabadie alain souchon benjamin
biolay et carla bruni
voilà et ensuite julien sous la
direction de jean claude petit vous
faites ce qu'on appelle des sessions à
l'ancienne ça vous enfermer tout le
monde dans un studio où le faire plein
de pistes les unes après les autres en
fait un tout le monde jouait les acteurs
chantent avec quoi ouais voilà alors des
jazzmen d'enfer il ya jean luc ponty mai
dibango philippe katerine toots
thielemans qui est vraiment un type
extraordinaire qu un harmoniciste corps
le plus grands harmonicistes du monde
qui verse faisant passer bien 90 films
dans les films des années 50
je dois quand même un sacré culot non de
reprendre tous ces standards croit quand
on chante comme c'est mon cas depuis
longtemps on se doit à chaque fois
décidé de proposer quelque chose de
nouveau aux gens après le public des
sites ma flamme c'est la médaille c'est
pas très nouveau justement vous passez
une nouvelle phase on était complètement
nouveau la fenêtre du français là dessus
hésiter vachement quand j'étais le
premier des critiques là dessus ce que
je connais c'est tellement bien ses
chansons dans les versions originales
qu'il ya vraiment eu un tabou a renversé
pour mettre ça en français qu'est ce qui
vous a décidé à vous lancer là dedans
parce que vous savez quand même que tout
le monde va écouter sans se disant
est-ce que c'est aussi bien est-ce que
c'est moins bien enfin c'est pas comme
la seule issue original certains disent
que autant que d'interprètes c'est un
disque de compositeurs amoureux oui on
va faire un test julien vous allez au
piano avec vos musiciens je vous balance
et vous balancer les versions les unes
et vous allez nous montrer ce que vous
en avez fait merci alors on commence
avec une chanson de frank sinatra qui
s'appelle witchcraft jette ce soit
oh
elle est en enfer
[Musique]
m'enfin
sous ma mère
chouette
bah oui ce pape il puise dans faire
quand j'ai mis à terre alors maintenant
julien on va continuer avec une chanson
qui s'appelle you do something to me
chantait par frank sinatra
[Musique]
à vous ça a été mis en paroles par alain
souchon
un grand
adam aux yeux
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
où je me perds
si je veux noah s'est bien fait
[Musique]
est ce que c'est vous
au doute
[Musique]
départ
où
menés par les vélib est mené par le bout
du nez
ce sont des paroles d'alain souchon sur
ustream tommy et maintenant on passe
julien à de véritables view carottes
choux world qui lui aussi donc a fait un
disque de reprises jeudi à sion ainsi on
fait
[Musique]
m
car les
là
[Musique]
2 et 3 10 jours
macho
[Musique]
la lune
la faune
un jour
si je
c
session
obsession obsession se sert d'elle en
france et maxime le forestier et
maintenant mesdames messieurs you go to
man die by holiday
rendre muet
oui
m
blackboard
avoue julien
tu viens
dans ma terre
chan
surtout le soir
tavannes
[Musique]
je ne reste pas
es-tu rast
[Musique]
que fois
tu repars nous
tu viens
amateurs
[Musique]
chez toi
tu fouilles
[Musique]
si secret de shell
durand joue
[Musique]
tu laisses une
sans plus
sous
ouais tu viens là matin gignac vers
attention le plus en plus du
julie london fly me to the moon
m
une
oui
avant julien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant la nuit
ça tue
janot
[Musique]
en capsules
ces mots
tu
m
[Musique]
allons un taxi
aïeux
s'il ya
votre peau
je t'aime
rolande à la lune merci jeu
elle serait donc de sens
gignac heures comme
je pense que ce plat ce que tu en penses
le rang je pense que le test est positif
ça va très positif
et puis à ça ça c'est le premier single
j'suis ray jusqu'à mars
si je suis seul
chaud
ouais jules à leur merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes complètement habité par ses
chances terrible parce que quand vous
avez recommencé à écrire vous est
influencé par sa non oui mais je pense
qu'il restera me restera du très bon de
tout ça mais ça va faire une information
supplémentaire dans mon petit ordinateur
vous allez tenir là le irvine berline ou
le colporteur ou le haïr à gershwin
jusqu'à baby 21e siècle ce que ta maison
dans la vie c'est d'apprendre de
continuer d'apprendre toujours bien
julien le plus dur reste à venir parce
que c'est un garçon bien élevé
jamais un mot plus haut que l'autre est
un gros mot dans les chansons jamais
jamais julien est un type très correct
donc on va vous faire une interview
mauvaises langues
[Applaudissements]
alors julien je vais vous demander
quelque chose d'encore plus difficile
que ce que vous venez de faire c'est
dire du mal des gens alors on va
commencer très facile on va commencer
avec saddam hussein avait bien trouvé
une saloperie à dire sur lui une
saloperie c'est pas difficile
n'arrangent pas la pression saddam
hussein qui l'avait très mauvais goût là
quand j'ai vu c'est pas l'air très bien
trop loin déjà ne pense pas non mais je
vais surveiller tonton langage parce que
les gens je me lâche un peu les gardes
je me lâche ce soir alors une méchanceté
vraiment sur ben laden je viens je sais
que c'est un petit peu d'ici samedi vers
l'ip open ben laden ben laden faut qu'il
fasse attention là l'air malade tooway
ça m'a vexé ça m'a vexé savez c'est bon
on va faire on va nous faciliter un peu
les choses méchancetés sur hitler
les méchancetés suis même pas janvier
non ils méchancetés sur hitler
ça c'est pas dur alors y'en a plein de
méchanceté a trouvé méchancetés sur iker
petite [ __ ]
oh non on ne sait pas pourquoi vous avez
connu eva braun non j'ai pas coller la
brawn mais on a des bouquins qui nous
explique effectivement il avait des
problèmes sexuels c'est pas bon non mais
sera maintenant ça peut expliquer le
reste quand même temps j'essaie de vous
aider envie d'envahir la pologne qui rit
non non c non c 1
non mais c'est pas bien non alors il
méchancetés sur hitler basse et plus
grands bourreaux de l'histoire voilà
alors maintenant augmenter un petit peu
différent et une méchanceté sur patrick
bruel
mais j'en suis sûre patrick bruel
en plus je savais que ce serait terrible
et je vois bientôt besoin est
parce que je vais chanter avec lui je
vais pas trop engagé je vais médias faux
qui maigrissent un peu voilà très bien
d'ailleurs
domicilié à coeur c'est quoi je viens
vers vous premier toujours votre site
votre fructose la part gardé à vue la
solution soit comme à la ville et tout
le monde moi et c'est de la course et
les capotes
c'est pas des capotes afin que pèse
toujours des aliments ça fait du bien
évidemment alors on continue guy bedos
les méchancetés sur un peu de ce guide
d'eau douce moi je dirai rien parce que
mon ami 10 ans serait conseillé que mes
chances je supplie peugeot je préfère
les sketches de jeu que jean loup
dabadie lui écrivait que les revues de
presse
d'accord bah voilà ta font là mais tu
connais pas il ya là pour lui c'est
terrible si l'épreuve chanter les
morceaux qu'il a chanté ne sait rien
christophe dechavanne qui est obligé de
faire le ménage dans le loft à leu leu
nice people de tf1 la structure julien
un truc concia ce qu'est ce qui veut
dire pâques
qu'est ce que tu veux dire par il a fait
le ménage il est à l'étape a vu passer
l'aspirateur un bond est allé passer
l'aspirateur en une semaine ne passe pas
très bien
alors ça c'est trop méchant voir pardon
il ya une époque où il y avait un truc
est un peu systématique c'est qu'il
aimait bien se faire faire pipi dessus
par des animaux dans une entrevue à
l'émission oui oui si c'est assez
méchant parce que tu dis qu'il s'en
priver ça devient méchant non non moi je
connais pas en privé c'est peut-être pas
transiger il faisait défaut je suis pas
des professionnels comme vous je me suis
votre maison si on a tendance à peine
méchante us s est alors attention
attention luc ferry une méchanceté sur
le ministre de l'éducation nationale luc
ferry il va couler non méchant ça oui
pour un ferry libé ils ont atterri à la
dérive je ne lis plus les girouettes
méchant avec luc ferry alors qu'est ce
que je pourrais dire une très grande
méchanceté méritent ils vraiment la
jolie femme qu'il aa
ouais ouais aulas alors ça c'est un truc
que je veux dire quoi zapping assurez la
j'ai bien vous êtes des emplois oui y
avait d'autres morts
alors ça c'est pas sympa ces années ci
avec tout un tas batman est violent
d'après ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est que moi je il m'arrive de déjeuner
ou de dîner avec lui assez souvent avant
j'espère qu'il prendra sa très bien
méritée prendra ça pour comme un hommage
mais oui ça fait donc donc ce que je
veux dire section d'affilée moi il ya
plein d'autres à dire tu as dit qu'on
était des [ __ ] voilà l'origine bien
et maintenant mesdames messieurs le plus
difficile à nam il reste plus difficile
de tous pour julien clerc julien vous
êtes prêts vous allez me dire du mal
julien clerc de guillaume durand votre
ami du mali guillaume durand votre grand
ami guillaume durand je pense que avec
le bon service qu'il est au tennis il
devrait arrêter de me servir mon coup
droit qui est mon meilleur qu'on ait
besoin d'essayer de plus chercher mon
revers cela dit même avec ça il me bat
donc c'est désespérant et en tant
qu'animateur vous avez une je trouve
très bon entendeur et mater les
meilleurs joueurs de tennis
mauvaise idée
la maison blanche
messieurs
non
et maintenant
voici qu'à des oliviers
[Applaudissements]
je vais
est ce que je peux dire une petite chose
je voudrais remercier djamel saluer
parce qu'il a parlé du maroc il a pas
oublié de parler de l'algérie comme j'ai
de la famille là-bas je les salue les
ombrages soirée spéciale reçoit et j'en
ai aplatit bonsoir les amis bonsoir
thierry les amis de la famille salem
monaco avant de commencer une question
que tout le monde se pose mais c'est
vrai que la réponse pourrait peut-être
tuer l'intérêt de votre film qui a tué
pamela rose
alors le coupable c'est bah oui chaque
fois qu'un mec le sait alors c'est un
film qui s'appelle donc mais qui a tué
pamela rose 5 millions d'euro s et la
gomme ou kbc lago manque
qu'est ce qu'on dit à la gaumont merci
c'est gentil c'est sympa la gomme au
quand même
et en plus ils font 400 salles pour la
sortie donc une arme 400 ça c'est pas
venu échapperez pas je crois qu'on peut
la malle gens non c'est même pas la
peine d'essayer d'échapper à ce fil vous
n'y échapperez pas alors c'est un film
qui est réalisé par eric lartigau
il est parent avec lartigau avec
lartigau cagnotte ouais
les parents des personnes non mais non
il peut pas être parent avec quelqu'un
c'est pas possible c'est un tout petit
homme il est tout petit il est tout
fripé alors avec vous il ya donc gérard
darmon jean-paul rouve thierry frémont
françois cluzet alain chabat al-hasaba
sera toujours bien là j'ai draco aller
alain chabat il a fait partie d'une
troupe
mais nul n'est rien été à la barre de la
compagnie créole campagne c'est bon pour
le moral c'est bon pour le moral
je sais que j'ai bien qu on va faire un
disque de reprises la compagnie que ça
fait chanter les nuages déconner qatar
oman et qatar
ouais ça pourrait marcher les immigrés
production et sa basse jusqu'aux des
achats chabat nous a demandé de faire de
devenu avant le film vous pouvez passer
le plaisir qu'on a eus parce qu'on adore
alain évidemment beaucoup de gens aussi
pour le même et il fut un chanteur de
country et le plus vrai que nature
alors le pitch je le fais vous le faites
thierry en hommage au no majo pas c'est
que nous avons là quand même passé voire
de la région
est ce que tu peux faire le pitre s'il
te plait je fais le pitié alors rippert
et bulitt sont deux agents qui
travaillent pour le fbi ils sont envoyés
à bord neuf villes où une jeune
stripteaseuse dénommé pamela rose est
retrouvé assassiné dans une chambre de
motel harkis c'est toute l'histoire est
là il se heurte aux policiers locaux
emmenés par le shériff marleix qui
jouait par jean paul rouve a et
l'animateur de radio joué par gérard
darmon qui s'appelle phil cannon voilà
c'est parfait c'est génial c'est un
pitch c'est le début or à celle d'un
prénom
comment vois tu le fais après comment
vont-ils faire pour retrouver l'assassin
effectivement alors ce qui est
extraordinaire dans le film c'est que
c'est un film qui a été tourné dans la
dans la banlieue parisienne
oui et qu'on se croirait aux états unis
on se croit vraiment à barneville
c'est tout à fait étonnant vous avez dit
et c'est vrai le premier film américain
entièrement français washington est à
créteil ouais hein et usb c'est la cité
universitaire du xiiie arrondissement
exactement
incroyable c'est peut-être ce pognon
comme une embrouille quelque part
pierre savary lazy tu veux dire que ce
manège aurait pu tourner là-bas
largement l'argent mis plein les
fouilles
non non non c'était génial c'est marrant
mais franchement drôle d'aller tourner à
mennecy à créteil en ville dans la liste
le tour de paris une cité elle est comme
ça le soir vous rentriez à la maison on
rentre à la maison tout va bien bon
c'était cool faille et une vraie
intrigue l'unreal très soignée qu'est ce
que je peux dire de plus moi qui sait
peut-être un peu drôle aussi non thierry
meyssan va le voir en regardant la bande
annonce karine way manille
petite ville tranquille un meurtre
sauvage d'une population qui vit dans
l'angoissé une police locale déboussolés
mais heureusement le et pia et a envoyé
ses deux meilleurs sa chambre je vois
que vous ètes recommandé par stevie
wonder
donc j'ai pas vraiment le choix ce
dernier condamné ce qu'est john pizza
panne il a été recruté pour avoir mangé
de zaba exécuté pour avoir mangé de la
viande mangée le groupe abba pouvons
vous l'affirmer aujourd'hui nous allons
trouver qui a tué pamela rose
ringo dit bingo pas de panique en fait
vu pour la première les informations
jeannie longo bindi
c'est très simple nous appliquons les
bonnes vieilles méthodes du fbi avant
tout respecter la population locale les
coûts de casino doit être hommage tant
qu'on ne parle alors tu retombes en tant
qu chez moi j'étais gros de bo le touche
à rien qu'on a lavé la victime à l'eau
de javel et on s'est coupé les autres
dans la pièce fait pas le bureau du fbi
a mis à notre disposition son meilleur
matériel
l'odeur c'est quoi cette caisse pourri
c'est une voiture de collection de
prestige on s'appelle commence une fois
à djabla aucoin
là ça va
inspecteur me sentais les cabinets mais
qui a tué pamela rose merci ce sera tour
mais qui a tué pamela rose
écoutez je vous ai dit ce que je savais
c'est tout moi je pense plutôt que vous
savez que vous en savez plus que vous ne
savez
martinoli
il a tué pamela rose
avez vous à entrer à tout - il ya les
arrestations avec les voitures de police
l'américaine avec les giraud qui tourne
ya des scènes de morgue évidemment comme
dans tous les hommes dans tous les
grands films américains
il ya des scènes cultes par exemple
quand vous avez la main dans la main de
johnson 25 juin je vais par greg germain
et vous arrêtez pas le mec est dans le
coma il n'arrive pas à tirer la main
pour passer une journée avec la main il
ya aussi cette histoire quand vous êtes
dans un bar avec une fille vous lui
faites une vanne ça passe pas du tout à
ce menu tout et j'appelle le service
après vente c'est-à-dire sens prévale et
de timéo nabokov s'il vous plaît le mec
corrige la vanne sections économiques
ont ébranlé mais valent ils appellent
ces services là et restera quatre jours
une solution c'est quoi le numéro tu
l'appelles souvent toi il ya un mec qui
demande un autographe au shérif marley
interpréter donc par jean paul rouve et
puis lucie notre avis pourquoi vous
demandez aux graphismes si j'adore les
robins et moi j'adore ce genre d'humour
si ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on a
quand on a vu le film la première fois
on s'est dit c'est exactement le film
qu'on voulait faire c'est vraiment ce
que ce que ce qu'on fait depuis dix ans
sur grand écran
espèce de tout est remontée d'un coup et
on a eu l'occasion de le faire le saut
au cinéma ça donne envie d'aller le voir
sauter montée d'un coup et je suis bon
bout du mur c'est que c'est un film très
chiadé parce qu'avec l'article où il a
fait un film comme dit chabal rfm film
très chic et usec lartigau fait ce qu'il
a fait l'article où elle a fait la pub
pour les bouloches un examen visuel
monsieur halak avec un tir est très
gênant mais je savais pas ce qui est
énorme
ouais c'était nord donc c'est pour ça
que dans le film ont des pulls et on est
tout le temps en train de se laver
bien à tous les cas c'est un vrai film
américain et donc on va vous faire caler
olivier une interview à l'américaine
donc j'ai fait les belles soirées we can
comment avez vous reçu le scénario du
film
c'est à dire que c'était un soir chez
moi ça a frappé à la porte
c'était un peu d un poney qui frappé à
ma porte et sur le dos du codé il y
avait un scénario de s'accrocher avec
avec du scotch est le poney est reparti
sans dire au revoir et c'est là que j'ai
compris que les pro d2 ne parlait pas ah
oui d'accord je crois qu'avec que c'est
le premier film que vous faites en
france pourquoi accepter de tourner en
france d'être au sommet de votre
carrière à yop hommes vous savez j'ai
déjà essayé de tourner dans différents
pays du monde
on m'a refusé alors j'ai dit la belgique
liechtenstein le luxembourg maintenant
soviétique
tous les réalisateurs avec qui j'ai
travaillé mon dit seule chose et on dit
tu es vraiment à chier alors
d'ailleurs je suis arrivé en france et
en france on m'a dit vas-y vas-y on en a
rien à [ __ ] cible barbarie
alors qu'adp merci d'être avec nous
merci d'être avec nous ce soir et
d'avoir choisi tout le monde en parle
pendant le tournage ce qu'est ce qui
vous a le plus manqué est ce que là la
production a assuré sur les [ __ ] et la
drogue
[Musique]
vous savez sur le tournage nous n'avions
pas le pas aux prostituées à la drogue
par contre aux avions des poupées
gonflables que nous avions le droit de
ou deux gros fûts les trois à quatre
fois par jour et à la place de de la
coke nous avions des petits gâteaux des
petits lu pour concasser convertir et
c'était vraiment très bon et je me suis
vraiment éclaté et j'adore la france
pour ça même si la france et j'adore
votre émission
cad
en tant qu'américain paris comment avez
vous vécu l'opposition qui a eu entre la
france et les etats-unis au sujet de la
guerre d'irak
un coach ne vous savez
j'ai vécu près aux états unis j'ai
quarante mille têtes de bétail j'habite
dans le vide quantique donc les états
unis je connais bien d'ailleurs premier
prix lancé en perd 10 heures c'est une
fausse question c'est un faux problème
l'opposition entre la france et les
états unis jeudi tout ça pousse emma
nous sommes tous terriens avant d'être
français ou américains là c'est bien
mais cadeau je décèle un léger accent
est ce que vous parleriez français vous
[Musique]
joue mais joe jeu tout
ouais lauvray tu l'ouvrés lula devrait
louvre est le vrai sens que les gens la
pression sur bordeaux agen
comment oui je tombe en levrette you
mean to johnny hallyday oui johnny
hallyday johnny hallyday
le fils at-elle mes pièces tué pamela
rose ontario hier jean paul roux viande
avant
saab a failli à tout le monde paul
eluard son sort le 4 juin
mais qui a tué pamela
et maintenant
je sais
[Musique]
mais si cristina marocco
[Applaudissements]
ans
[Musique]
ayew
mais entre les deux plus grands clubs
français
seul coup entre la poire et le fromage
vous êtes comme une soupe à saint avit
des belles danses attention c'est bien
je voulais dire que tu es très
je lis alors que l'italienne inutile de
le dire quand on vous voit on comprend
une option indique baril d'abord
chanteuse actrice milan en france depuis
1999 et 6,1 maroco et on vous avait été
découverte par le grand public dans
cette chanson avec marc lavoine
[Musique]
très belle chanson un très très très
très jolie chanson alors je viens vous
avez fait dans votre disque studio 2 duo
donc un avec véronique sanson avec carla
bruni voilà donc c'est très bien c'est
très bien porter les duos en ce moment
ça va tranquille oui on va faire un duo
avec cristina marocco avoir embrassé ou
allez-y faites quelque chose s'est pas
pendu comme ça on sait le temps passe et
christina le nombre de gens qui se sont
rencontrés sur des plateaux télé c'est
un croyez qu'ils ont baisé après bien
sûr est énorme alors christina extrait
de votre album qui sortira en septembre
cette chanson ce single qui s'appelle
pas de problème
[Musique]
oh
orlando exige l'équipe
c
je te
[Musique]
non
mais si la mare en quoi bellemare
[Musique]
donc maintenant l'objectif c'est d'avoir
le numéro de port c'est un numéro vert
c'est pas réfléchi mais zéro taxe et la
musique alors qu'est stinat vous êtes
d'origine sicilienne où vous êtes né à
turin en 1972
ça va un jour pourquoi oui ah mais ça ne
va pas c'est pas vrai la mère dit c'est
bien de ça veut dire parce qu'on apprend
beaucoup de choses on a envie
d'apprendre sur aimé ce qu'il a vu
avance mais pardon moi j'essaie de
calculer combien ça fait en euro lâche
vous avez ça doit faire ça fait trente
merde ça va tu vois les choses et
régionale de santé très bon non mais
c'est vrai pourtant julien faire de
s'emporter très beaux mecs sont mauvais
c'est vrai parce que dès que la chaleur
et on sait très bien qui alors votre
père qui n'avait un magasin de perruques
oui c'est incroyable ça a du bon
g zoug 2 et par le programme dans le
film cas de nom mais qui a tué pamela
rose
vous avez non c'est un animal mort que
je sois là et ces listes ont un
mais bon ce que j'ai le père le père d
un truc vachement important tiré a dit
ça me va bien c'est à calvisson arrivait
bien non c'est pas ça comme disait mon
grand père j'ai la tête pieds nus voilà
c'est vrai en plus donc le père de kevin
avait un magasin de peru qui en même
temps et et compositeur de chansons
histoires amateur bien sûr et c'est lui
qui vous a poussé les au conservatoire
et il m'a inscrite à l'examen de
l'admission et après je les fais un
rigolant et finalement ça a changé un
peu ma vie parce que question je vous
aime beaucoup
moi aussi rapidement mais disent mais
vraiment c'est que j'ai une passion pour
les italiennes et là d'un coup j'en ai
une en face de moi
qu'est ce que tu as dit salma fais toi
tu aimes tu la prends donc après la mort
de votre père donc vous prenez des cours
de comédie de théâtre ou fait de la télé
et vous arrivé en france en 1999 avec un
fiancé italien et le mec repart quand ça
s'est un peu cherché
voilà pourquoi il est reparti en fait on
était partis et on était 3e
bravo mais par un prompt renfort
le projet personnes sans savoir s'ils
versent deux garçons et vous c'est ça
lui versant une fille je sens qu'on va
te sais pas pourquoi mais avec une
mezzanine
mais en bas est bien d'accord
bah oui c'est normal c'est logique un
plus qui dormait en bas vous non non je
sais pas mais je me renseigne
comme on fait connaissance simplement on
est arrivé pour un mois comme ça juste
pour découvrir la ville et simplement
moi je
j'avais j'avais vraiment envie de rester
parce que je sentais que tout paris
c'était une ville pour moi et alors
heureusement parce qu'un jour dans un
studio vous rencontrer marc la merde il
est sympa dans la vie marquant savez
tous ce nom là on le connait une radio
demandant là une apathie qui si elle est
comme ça devant les caméras de
télévision dans l'animation dirt et oui
quoi tu disais cela de marc lavoine ball
à la latte
nous on dit je sais pas c'est pas mon
papa m'a balancé un mec assists
moi je vais vous dire je viens
j'aimerais être ami avec vous vraiment
pas ce que vous défendez vos potes c'est
bien c'est vraiment un être gentil ya
pas beaucoup de gens gentils sur terre
et lui c'est vraiment un vrai gentil
mais ça le conte par excellence pour
dire les choses
une vulgaire vulgaire me chante des
espèces de marc lavoine ça veut tout
dire
ça veut dire c'est entre nous c'est bien
gentil qui mérite sa jolie salle julia
se pourrir non mais je viens rigole pas
avec ça tu as compris je veux dire c'est
comme guillaume toi
il est gentil dans son âme de pièces
dames et des peurs qui vendait de la
drogue à des enfants quand même il faut
le savoir
avec toutes les vannes afin de profiler
le futur c'est ça le grand public il a
violé des animaux bien sûr des peaux des
animaux et des allemands ritter
bien partenaires de corse nombre oui
leurrons pas si c'était aujourd'hui que
six mois c'est déjà ça allait changer un
petit peu de bon alors on va voir
christina on va voir si vous êtes
capable de vous intégrer en france et de
devenir une grande vedette française si
vous pensez comme la majorité des
françaises on va faire une interview
opinion publique
alors c'est une interview qui est basée
sur un sondage ifop
vous connaissez l'ifop c'est une société
très pop folk américain ça veut dire un
truc et narbonne ces stages sinon on va
voir donc si je pensais comme la
majorité des françaises 25% des femmes
considèrent christina que la taille du
sexe chez l'homme c'est important
est-ce que vous vous sentez proche des
25 % ou des 75%
je sais pas je les 25% sont quittés mais
non je plaisante celle de son père est
malade pour l'instant on est tous donc
tour on est toujours dans la course
non mais
ça va ça lui les gens
tu sens on entend des bons cépages
locaux des tricoteries pourrait
cependant ils seront 120 minutes sur un
concours de [ __ ] tout de suite ça on va
y arriver là donc voilà j'en ai une
bombe 38% et fille cécile ifop un
tranquille c'est pas moi 38% et filles
pratiquent la fellation
est ce que vous sentez proche des 38% ou
des autres voilà ça beaucoup trop de
suite quand tu vas 62% de shenyang c'est
incroyable il a répondu il a répondu à
votre place
46% des femmes et ça c'est beaucoup en
revanche de la matière grasse 46% 36%
des femmes accepteraient de faire
l'amour en échange d'un cadeau même si
elles ont pas envie aa c'est l'histoire
vraie envie du cadeau non de faire un
cours d'accor non mais c'est incroyable
non mais ça doit être offrirait quoi
pour faire l'amour j'offre une audi tt
comme autant attiré par la neige qui ont
payé mais toutes options avec tout ça
alors
christina et je peux vous avez proche de
la majorité du 46%
non absolument pas même pas pour un
énorme cadeau mais on s'est fait tout
seul à réellement on va là parce que moi
j'ai fait des italiens à l'école des
trajets alors est ce que la télé partout
bat oloron d'helmand donc pas pour tout
l'or du monde
ouverture
j'y viens veulent m'aider alors
christine à lui pour cent des filles de
25 à 34 ans alors là vous êtes
complètement dans la cible un rêve de
faire l'amour avec une autre femme
qu'est-ce que je suis plate de 8% dans
les 90 92 % absolument vous êtes vous
êtes proche de là vous êtes une vraie
française la douce pour cent des femmes
de moins de 35 ans sont tentés par une
expérience sado maso non je ne suis pas
tenté par ça mais je suis embarrassé il
aimerait l'être mais ne discute pas mais
ça me venaient 91 % des filles de 18 à
24 ans considèrent la fidélité comme une
valeur tout à fait actuel pour moi la
fidélité c'est
oui je suis d'accord avec ce pourcentage
de femmes c'est une valeur absolue la
fidélité qui qu'on peut avoir ou pas
avoir comme valeur mais c'est une valeur
qui n'a pas d'époque pour moi c'est
exister c'est bon et bien cette petite
je vais tourner en rond de aux mille et
une splendide oui je sais c'est pas
qu'il ait écrite d'ailleurs sinon
qu à peine
home est sorti en septembre la mission
et maintenant chaque oeil arnaud clément
or dans le milieu
bonsoir bonsoir décidemment au pot
arnaud clément bonsoir comment ça va
vous fait pas mal à vous fait pas mal
parce que l'indiquent j'ai commencé
votre septième roland garros et en
attendant vous publiez arnaud clément
passing potes chez mango sport
[Musique]
voilà passé une pote c'est un livre qui
raconte votre amitié avec sébastien
grosjean
c'est un livre que vous avez écrit
ensemble mais vous êtes seul ce soir
parce qu'il est blessé
oui la petite gêne à la cuisse depuis
depuis un moment et mais c'est pas grave
laurent baffie vous allez remplacer
sébastien grosjean dont quatre pattes la
chance de prendre la place de laurent
baffie toi tu fais laurent baffie et
l'europe et sébastien grosjean
c'est un jeu de rôle cette émission
voilà je vais pas la leur
laurent baffie au pied levé merci
laurent merci beaucoup
toujours très gentil avec tout d'accord
il n'a pas eu la pâte habile il n'a pas
tu habites sébastien sébastien thierry
tulasne
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france et
est inquiet est ce que vous serez
vraiment à roland garros lundi malgré
votre gêne à la cuisse
je serai là sur le court lundi au gabon
sera pas là bien alors quelques buts en
plus quand son but
y aller à pied qui lui est chargé de
faire de dakar
il est chargé tôt qu un tiers de ma
fille tu fais du grand chelem agassi me
sentais bien dans le premier teaser qui
voulait faire une vanne bien alors
quelques mails avant de commencer un
mail de guy forget le capitaine de
l'équipe de france de tennis qui dit à
tous les deux sébastien arnaud
franchement à 24 heures de roland garros
vous n'avez pas autre chose à [ __ ]
qu'il allait faire les cons chez
ardisson avec député de la drogue
cc du pcc du pénis bon j'arrête ces
produits n'ont cessé mais c'est bien
c'est cette nouveauté un foot jour 1c
partage des tâches avec on parle de
peut-être drogues les plus spéciaux s'il
ya un petit peu un peu tu es un petit
peu plus de pression pour renoir avant
roland-garros que dans les tournants
avant donc pour moi ça me change un
petit peu un petit peu l'esprit et je
fais autre chose et je pense à autre
chose donc ça me fait du bien aussi
il est beau son bouquin il est très
travaillé et très travaillées alors un
mail maintenant d'henri leconte
alors les gars ça fait quoi de gagner
des matchs vous me raconterez
dernièrement je peux pas trop répondre
sur la wii un mail d'amélie mauresmo
vous voulez votre revanche au bras de
fer les mecs vous avez dans un
un journal dernièrement halal paraît ans
dans des photos où elle est vraiment
très jolie très sexy un très très sexy
c'est qu'il ressemble à amélie mauresmo
non non je trouve qu'elle ressemble à
roch voisine moins bien alors passing
potes donc c'est le bouquin que vous
avez choisi avec votre ami sébastien
grosjean ici présents bah c'est
l'histoire d'une amitié
parce que sébastien et arnaud sont
déliées sans sexe comme amitié sans sexe
vous êtes lié par le métier évidemment
vous êtes tennismen tous les deux par
vos origines provençales puis aussi le
fait que vous êtes connus très jeunes à
l'école de tennis avec sébastien très
jeunes auraient enfin très jeune
ça fait on a commencéà
en 12 ans non on s'est rencontré à la
pointe avancée en retrait c'est à cet
âge des benjamins mais on a commencé à
s'entraîner ensemble vert
cet engin oui alors la première
rencontre sais pas qui c'est sous la
douche
la première rencontre sébastien me
l'avait trouvé un petit peu grassouillet
je crois j'ai trouvé va tout le monde le
trouvait un petit il s'est un petit peu
un petit peu rond avant aujourd'hui il
est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus affûté
il a grandi mais à un moment donné il
était lipton vraiment un petit peu en
bas c'est normal urgent il veut manger
du fromage beaucoup alors arnaud à la
même époque
vous vous avez commencé à jouer au
tennis contre nos à dire que nora était
venu c'était pour les enfants de la
terre donc avait une sélection et les
élèves avaient le droit de jouer contre
n'aura enfin ce qu'ils avaient gagné la
sélection et ils vous demandent noah de
jouer doucement parce qu'il est blessé à
cette époque là et vous en faites pas du
tout tapé dans la balle vous jetez
j'étais petit je me rendais pas bien
compte qu'ils avaient été qualifiés sur
mon cours et j'avais eu la chance de jeu
sur le central demain un club qui était
assez grand il y avait peut-être quatre
mille 4000 personnes et là j'étais petit
c'était très intimidant et il y en a et
fait quelques jeux alors c'est bon ils
étaient l'édition du jour mais j'étais
très petits pouvaient se permettre de
vraiment de jouer à cloche pied alors
vous sébastien en 1991 vous regardez
leconte et forget battre les américains
la finale de la coupe davis à lyon
et là j'ai eu le déclic je me dis un
jour j'y serai avec mon pote arnaud et
je vois cela nous a donné la raison
c'est exactement ça qui fait je sais pas
ce que je suis et jean paul c'est vrai
que ça tu es bon tu pourrais remplacer
tous les invités oui c'est moi julien
clerc femmes je vous aime
donne envie d'acheter du temps pendant
ce temps julien je l'aimais arnaud
clément baroin beaucoup sont bien tous
les supers vous êtes devenus amis en
floride vous avez passé quelques temps
en floride tué d'occasion manquée ce qui
s'est passé là-bas
comment vous expliquez des couchers de
soleil magnifique et proximité à une
complicité et puis une peña qui nous a
beaucoup rapprochés mais il ya un truc
quand même c'est que sébastien ça ça
vous a un peu refroidi après la floride
c'est que ces patients nous a pas dit
que sa femme était enceinte
oui je l'appris là je ne savais pas
juste un tournoi où ça les complique et
tu le savais très bien alors que
sébastien non c'est vrai que c'était un
moment vraiment vous vous donnez j'avais
vraiment l'impression qu'on s'était
rapproché à prendre au mot très tard que
qu'il allait être papa donc ça sent son
premier enfant
sama
bah je vais pas dire ça m'a fait du mal
mais je me suis dit peut-être que tim la
panique peut-être que je compte pas
autant renoncer pas m'entraîner
sérieusement il m'a piqué mon entraîneur
à ma femme est tombée enceinte j'avais
peur que tu arrives à merde comme
d'habitude qui compte pour moi donc je
vous ai pris un petit peu
il a à ce moment là on attendait vous
êtes le vrai arnaud clément mais non
alors heureusement
heureusement il ya cette première
victoire en double qui vous a quand même
énormément rapprocher là cette fois je
veux dire que un c'est exceptionnel on
les attend chez grasset en bandits alors
de tourisme a donné sa langue si vous
êtes obligé de vous affronter en demi
finale de l'open d'australie
c'est un moment où votre amitié aurait
pu ne pas résister ça vous a vendu c'est
le sport il fallait qu'un gagnant le
savez vous savez on accepte les lois du
sport et je vais donner sa mère une fois
de plus tout est bien qui finit bien
non c'est vrai que ça vous a
définitivement raccroché si c'était
c'est clair que j'aurais la limite ça
aurait pu ça aurait pu nous éloigner et
au contraire c'était vraiment pour nous
dans un milieu c'était vraiment une
épreuve parce que là on nous la victoire
ou la défaite on peut pas là pas sûr
tous ces mots ce match là c'est moi qui
l'ait gagné il m'a pas ce que j'allais
vous l'avez minable se connaît j'étais
meilleure année que tennisman ce jour là
c'est d'ailleurs mais est donc pour
finir là-dessus et je savais que c'était
vous avez gagné un match comme ça et se
qualifier pour une finale de grand
chelem ce qui est un moment qui sera
peut-être unique dans ma carrière et ne
pas rire on aura des pannes vallée ont
choisi toit et de pas vraiment pouvoir
en profiter à fond parce que c'est
contre sébastien est forcément mais on
est des faits pour lui même si on est
très content d'être en finale
en tous les cas c'était preuve à
renforcer votre amitié et arnaud vous
êtes le parrain du fils de sébastien ce
qui est très extraordinaire c'est que la
première fois il ne dit même pas que sa
femme est enceinte et ensuite il devient
le parrain de son fils moi c'est une une
très belle histoire une sorte bien
française entre les gars par terre j'ai
réparé un alors arnoux il ya un truc
quand même qui m'étonne beaucoup j'ai
appris en lisant ce gars vous êtes accro
à céline dion
oui
10 ans ça fait partie de son
entraînement c'est resté celui de garder
son self control oui si vaste et si
j'étais vraiment très très fan en 95
sorti son premier album - enfin ce n'est
pas son premier roman français j'ai une
grosse bêtise mais même écrit par jane
goldman j'étais vraiment je suis tombé
amoureux de cet album là et puis après
20 mange ça s'est enchaîné
et puis j'avais 15 cd d'un moment donné
de céline dion et puisqu'il ya ces
gestes ou mes voitures tout le temps
dans le coffre de ma voiture est
abandonné par ma fracture aimons comme
des voitures fabriquées tous mes cd et
je les ai pas racheté depuis
depuis j'ai changé un petit peu ah bon
vous écoutez quoi me suis toujours fan
mais alizé j'adore aussi jeune et alizée
voilà bombing bien merci
et on la vit j'espère une population
très bien alors sébastien arnaud ceci
m'amène à vous poser les questions
interdites du tennis français
attention attention on pouvait
l'attendre tous les deux sébastien
arnaud pourquoi les français ne gagne
plus roland garros mais je pense
qu'arnaud sera le prochain à gagner ah
oui il a plus d'atouts que moi mais
pourquoi tu écoutes de la merde il se
concentre sur son jeu et rentre mieux
dans la balle bien alors en quelle année
henri leconte n'a pas gagné roland
garros et 3 6 4 1 6 4 1 sec 1 10
merci à sa wilander maintenant une
question très très importante comment
ferait les gens qui n'ont pas droit
comment ferait les gens qui ont un
attacks caravane si le tennis n'existe
pour mehdi dehbi de tennis
l'amendé congés payés bénéfique
simulation souvent posé des questions
sur l'intérêt mais jamais aussi pointue
et bravo vous êtes des questions
importantes sur tmc en tout cas il est
il est mûr pour roland garros car elle
trouve extrêmement zen de c'est vrai que
ces voix là il comprend pas tout non
plus arnaud les allées des invitations
pour roland garros et j'en ai way jeunes
ont bien peu si c'est pas assez
j'essaye de jouer la montée munger et
répété depuis
non
c'est bien
julien je vais vous laisser partir je
vais vous laisser aller vous coucher
parce que vous êtes lundi à roland
garros
oui je sais ce que c'est une petite
vacherie avant de partir je viens et je
vais vous dire vélo je trouve qu un peu
comme jules ferry je ne sais pas si vous
vous méritez votre femme
ah merci merci merci merci pour rien en
tous les cas merci merci julien bien
julien vous laisser filer vous aussi
arnaud va laisser filer et donc quand
vous attend donc lundi sur le court de
roland garros et et là on va vraiment
militer pour vous on va être moi je vais
enfin je vais avoir un tennisman aussi
en que j'aime et que j'ai envie de
swallow faut qu'il faut marquer des buts
a fouillé les talibans allez merci
juliette
enlevez moi merci
camille jullien
donc
j'accueille maintenant des rats jacques
v séries
[Musique]
après razak dci en amis de la maison
vous étiez à l'époque votre affaire
battait son plein vous êtes donc l'ex
bagagiste de roissy injustement
soupçonnés de terrorisme il ya quatre
mois et demi est finalement libéré quand
il a été pas tant que votre affaire en
fait était un complot monté par votre
belle famille les béchir y voilà donc là
vous êtes libres et ont publié
aujourd'hui un livre s'appelle
bagagistes à roissy présumés terroristes
et c'est chez michel lafon
[Musique]
oh
déjà j'ai écrit le livre avec un
journalier qui s'appelle aziz zemouri
qui je voulais rendre un hommage
[Applaudissements]
alors bonne situation s'est arrangée
puisque jeudi dernier à bérat zac
besseghir vous avez bénéficié d'un non
lieu
exactement comme ça c'est déjà un point
c'est déjà plutôt bien mais quand même
presque cinq mois datant à tout à fait
m'enfin on est quand même loin de voir
la justice reconnaître son erreur et
vous verser des indemnités suite à votre
incarcération quand même pas encore aux
indemnités mais on a déjà le non-lieu
déjà pas mal c'est un début alors
d'autant plus que le patron de la
brigade criminelle frédéric péchenard
lui il est pas du tout d'accord avec
l'analyse que vous faites de ce qui vous
était arrivé lui deal enquête a été
parfaite j'ai vu son article beaucoup de
méthode et sang-froid pourrait demander
quoi ça soit fait pas d'accord ouais ça
on était placé à deux extrémités donc
forcément on a chacun notre version
s'est avéré que moi depuis le début je
disais la vérité le genre du je restais
sur ma ligne de mire je me dis que la
vérité si méthodes et sang froid s'est
pas fait un innocent le jeune femme ils
ont mis des gifles
je sais les termes s'est déclarée d'être
là que même mon père m'a pas mis donc
surtout pour un nul insensé si je ravale
échos et puis quoi d'autre sur l'anc est
la manière dont a été mené l enquête
s'était tout de suite il faut voir le
titre du livre présumé terroriste
pourquoi à l origine mon lieu de travail
la religion oui surtout ma religion qui
a été bafoué pendant tous ces quinze
jours
bravo raconter cette enquête dans votre
livre abderrazak besseghir avec une
certaine ironie par exemple dit qu'avant
il ya un chien policier qui est
spécialisé donc pour trouver les
les armes et qui s'arrêtent sur le siège
bébé de votre voiture qui renifle comme
ça et en fait c'est parce que la veille
dit vous vous aviez acheté les merguez
que le sien il sentait l'odeur démarre
enfin où je sais pas maintenant
aujourd'hui ce qui est grave c'est que
les policiers font parler les chiens
maintenant deux ans pour moi c'est de la
tnt troisième moment ça peut être des
merguez
on a fait 2 à la rigueur donc un prix
cassés des merguez cd père mois du tnt
alors plus grave quand même dans cette
histoire vous affirmez que votre oncle
qui était en situation irrégulière en
france s'est vue proposer des papiers
s'il vous accusés de terrorisme c'est du
chantage c'est le chantage pur et simple
a pas d'autre mot je lis aussi bien
entendu de la bouche de mon oncle mais
de la bouche des policiers qui m'ont dit
simplement que toute ma famille à voler
avec m'avait culpabiliser pour pouvoir
justement essayer de soutirer des aveux
quoi sont plantés et puis parce que je
connais ma famille je me connais
moi-même
voilà une certaine fierté on l'a on est
issu d'un a été va dire élevé danse avec
certaines valeurs
alors vous affirmez dans votre lit que
les journalistes ne font pas d' enquête
et se contente de répéter ce que dit la
police est à dire de finalement de
communiquer les éléments que leur donne
la police vous affirmez d'ailleurs que
nicolas sarkozy a donné lui même des
informations à la presse
oui je vais faire ça à travers justement
ce zemmour et aziz qui est gens là est
lui-même se
ce nicolas sarkozy si je peux dire
monsieur parce que le monde n'a pas
appelé du tout comme ça de sources sûres
a reçu les journalistes du fameux
journal le parisien qui s'est bien
défoulé sur mon cas penser qu'un jour là
en disant tout simplement que je savais
le téléphone avait parlé donc ça venait
pas de n'importe qui donc si la plus
grosse autorités ont à dire sur ce
principe là lâche le mot et policiers en
bas ne peuvent que suivre alors dans
votre vie vous accuser la presse vous
accusez la justice vous accuser la
police
enfin finalement ce qui vous était
arrivé c'est quand même la faute de
votre belle famille c'est quand même
mieux comme entrée ce complot il n'y a
pas de racisme puisqu'ils sont d'origine
algérienne comme vous c'est les
personnes que je veux plus en entendre
entende parler plus du tout de ces
personnes là donc je demanderai pas
d'explication si certaines personnes
j'attends que la justice fasse son
travail et qu'après quatre mois de
mandat de dépôt quand même on relâche
ces gens là oui c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire la justice les a relâchés donc
ça permet aujourd'hui justement de ce
travail avec des pains d'explosif un et
qu'on risque mois de mandat de dépôt
donc au mieux ses balades avec la tnt
plutôt que attaché le sac d'une vieille
excuse et dans grandir la terrase accès
que eu en fait ils vous ont mis dans
cette situation ils ont demandé à
quelqu'un de mettre des explosifs dans
votre nom votre automobile et finalement
aujourd'hui sont libres ouais vous y
comprenez quelque chose non mais du coup
alors elle concerne et je ne suis pas
qu'elle voit quelqu'un je me trouve
quand je vois ça quand votre épouse
luisa et est décédé votre belle famille
avait porté plainte et ils disent quand
on les interviews ils disent que toute
façon ils vous accusent du meurtre de
louise à 2,2 de votre femme et ils
disent que finalement vous n'avez été
relâché que parce qu'on avait pas de
preuves
c'est grave franchement c'est très grave
ça me touche énormément plus que
l'histoire du terrorisme parce que ma
femme je l'aimais avant tout une
personne qui compte beaucoup pour moi
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
c'est une personne qui habite mes
pensées jamais de ma vie j'ai à prouver
à qui que ce soit de toute façon ce qui
s'est passé maintenant si j'écris libre
et que j'en ai parlé dans cet état là
c'est pour mon enfant avant tout
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais lorsque vous arrivez vous traîtres
femmes en feu et que c'est vous qui
l'éteignez qui lui permet de vivre
on va dire une lueur d'espoir de s'en
sortir de moi je pense pas que j'aurai
paris avec la vie de ma femme et la main
enfants quoi c'est vraiment à trois
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
maintenant moi si je tiens m'exprimer
par rapport à ça c'est vrai qu'elle
s'est immolé tout seul louisa disons le
doigt en présence de votre enfant mehdi
s'est aspergé de white spirit et ses
mille feux
c'est j'arriverai jamal expliquez moi je
reste toujours et c'est qu'elles sont là
pourquoi le pourquoi du comment je le
saurai jamais puisque la personne n'est
plus là ce personne ne peut expliquer ce
geste comme ça c'est un geste intime
personnel et auquel jusqu'aujourd'hui je
veux dire abderrazak ce qui a de toute
façon si elle voulait se suicider il ya
d'autres façons de se suicider à l'autre
et rock comme je vous ai dit c'était
intime et personnelle dont je pourrais
je pourrais jamais le comprendre
aujourd'hui vous dites que vous êtes
aussi détruit qu'après le décès de
louisa vous avez plus de voitures est
suivi par un psychologue vous êtes sous
tranquillisants ça va pas mieux la
savait qu'on était ennemi public numéro
1 pendant 15 jours vous pour l'âge de
fleury mérogis
j'avais ma mère et mon enfant est ainsi
que mes amis il va proches familles qui
sont venues me récupérer à la sortie de
la prison après y avait plus rien
comment voulez-vous vous réadapter vont
réhabiliter dans cette société là c'est
la même société qui m'a mis dans cet
état là je pense que le minimum j'aurais
peut-être reçu des excuses ou j'aurais
peut-être rencontrer les personnes qui
monte est giflé ou les personnes qui ont
commandité le fait comment vont en
prison ou tout simplement des excuses
vous lorsque vous voyez des journalistes
qui s'exprime lors qu'ils ont inventé
une histoire de mallettes ils ont failli
trouver un tank presque gare à roissy
n'était pas loin de trouver un tank
mais ces gens là aujourd'hui même à la
télévision il se refuse de s'excuser
c'est un jeu peu convaincant vis de ma
vie a été violée c'est clair c'est clair
aujourd'hui ma vie n'appartient plus
puisque tout le monde sait ce qui se
passe dans la vie pas ce qui s'est passé
dans ma vie donc quelque part le jardin
secret
compte tenu de sa des rasades je vais
rester ici en france allait continuer à
vivre en france charles là
à qui vous en voulez le plus aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à qui j'en veux plus
si je dois que faire dressé un podium
jeudi un numéro à la fin du shérif à la
belle-mère avec une mention spéciale
oui ensuite à la police et médaille de
bronze à la justice mais ce que la celle
enquête de police qui a été mal fait
donc pas me fait mal orienté ils ont
quand même libéré à la sortie quand même
mieux qu'un jour quand même c'est pas
moi vous avez entre les mains un
témoignage qui conte comme au niveau du
timing ne correspond pas vous avez une
description de la personne qui ne
correspond pas lorsque vous décrivez à
telle heure vous étiez là alors que vous
étiez pas la queue il met dix jours pour
aller interroger ces mêmes personnes là
c'est la mauvaise foi bracket c'était de
la charge la charge la charge la
décharge ou l'étincelle de décharge est
venu de ma famille qui a bousculé un
petit peu c'est c'était trop gros seins
vous avez retrouvé un boulot là j'ai pas
été licenciés ou quoi que ce soit au
contraire c'était a été idéale sur ce
point là
ils m'ont même très soutenu je suis en
arrêt maladie actuellement savoir si je
vais reprendre mon boulot où ils n'ont
moi même c'est pas aujourd'hui sort plus
trop quoi je me sens bien très bien chez
moi d'or ça me fait encore un peu peur
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup merci le livre s'appelle
bagagistes à roissy présumés terroristes
c'est physique
monsieur michel lafon et c'est injuste
asaq b séduire merci beaucoup écrit avec
aziz zemouri et au figaro magazine merci
beaucoup au revoir mais hazard
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant michelle paddack
[Musique]
michel polac bonsoir heureux de vous
avoir avec nos michel bonsoir pensez
quoi de cette france là justement qui
envoie abderrazak besseghir pendant
quinze jours en tout rôle qui libère la
famille qui l'a foutu de là dedans
quatre mois après oui c'est pas nouveau
un pas nouveau
moi je veux pas minimiser ce qui était
arrivé à ce garçon mais il y a des seins
plus bas je pense à un pâtissier nantais
qui a été foutu en taule accusé de
meurtre et qui finalement été innocenté
mais des années après il ya eu pire
comme cas que le sien ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux musulmans
je dis pas qu'il ya pas de racisme et
tout le bataclan rennes c'est pas le
problème mais c'est qui pour le consoler
un peu ça n'arrive pas forcément des
erreurs judiciaires ça arrive à tout le
monde alors michel polac vous publié aux
presses universitaires de france
une correspondance avec le philosophe
clément rosset il s'appelle franchise
postale
[Musique]
alors michel qu'est né ce clément rosset
qui trouve grâce aux yeux d'un
misanthrope comme vous oui c'est la
question qui se posait hier dans un
débat qu'on a fait dans une librairie
disait je comprends pas encore
aujourd'hui pourquoi il s'est intéressé
à moi oui ne serait ce que parce que
nous sommes assez opposé son coin et que
par exemple c'est un de nos problèmes
c'est que il trouve que je m'indigne
trop et que
la sagesse dans la vie c'est pas de
s'indigner c'est pour ça que je laime
c'est parce qu'il m'apporte des des
contrepoids à mes défauts et donc ça
fait trente ans que je le pratique et
donc j'ai appris à me modérer un peu
vain alors au sujet du livre au sujet de
l'écriture vous dites que je le veuille
ou non je passe pour un homme de
télévision pour les intellos finalement
je suis comme bellemare guy lux c'est
terrible et oui oui ça fait une éternité
que ça m'arrive quand je travaillais
c'est pas sur france inter par exemple
si on m'invitait sur france culture en
10 euros non là c'est un saltimbanque 1
et quand j'ai travaillé pour europe 1
ont déjà eu lieu un peu trop intello ça
ça continue ouais bon on s'en foutait là
maintenant je m'en fous complètement
comme maintenant je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs de quoi je me fous plus c'est
le meilleur état c'est une des leçons de
ce livre tout à fait on va en parler
donc vous êtes un touche-à-tout vous le
dit d'ailleurs un caméléon
et oui j'ai fait plus de fausses couches
que je n'ai accouché d'oeuvre oui parce
que j'ai pas vous amener tous les
manuscrits qui sont dans mon armoire
mais il y a beaucoup de livres que
finalement je n'ai pas publié
je les ai pas tout à fait terminé 1 mais
je crois que je le dis dans le livre
aussi je dis que j'ai un certain goût
pour pour les oeuvres inachevées la
virtualité de l'art sert que vous dites
effectivement dans votre bouquin tout à
fait ou dit finalement les gens diraient
ils par actif a livré clément rosset ça
me suffirait finalement pas qu'on ait eu
l'idée c'est bon il est pas mal mais
c'est moi je suis assez comme ça c'est
exact a eu l'idée d'un film que tu vas
te regarder à le faire je vous l'avais
bien
ils sont allés au bout les deux d'argent
ouais et la moustache année où elle
s'est acheté un jour c'était à
montpellier il ya un épicier qu'il est
sur le pas de sa porte qui meurent gimli
bonjour monsieur bellemare le suis parce
qu'avant avant christine elle il avait
une belle fille lui avant qu'un des
oliviers l'a lâchement nathalie
beauchamp charlotte a gardé la cale
justement vous parlez de bellemare mais
c'est vrai que c'est un homme de télé
mais quand même d'une époque où la télé
avec un peu plus de sens qu'aujourd'hui
et et vous dites et cette terrible quand
vous dites ça vous dit
vous imaginiez étant jeune que la télé
pouvait être la nouvelle école du peuple
qui aujourd'hui ça paraît complètement
d'un ba oui moi j'irai aussi à un moment
mais on a tous cru que la télé pouvait
faire avancer les choses et puis c'est à
dos vraiment homéopathiques
quand vous avez été virés tf1 michel
polac que vous aviez 60 balais n'ont
même pas même pas et alors vous pensiez
vous réfugier dans une bergerie à la
montagne et vous êtes resté à paris
pourquoi à cause de votre santé vous
voyez pas dans un âge c'est là que
j'étais un parisien qui s'imaginaient
que c'est facile de vivre dans la
montagne
perdu dans un bled ou si on a pas
d'allumettes il faut faire 20 minutes de
route pour en trouver et
l'hiver j'ai découvert que c'était
beaucoup plus dur à vivre et donc mon
côté parisien est revenu j'ai déprimé
carrément et je suis rentré à paris
vous avez atteint une espèce de sagesse
aujourd'hui vous avez plus de désir ce
qui est quand même là la vraie
définition de la sagesse c'est le jour
on n'a plus de désir
vous avez appris à perdre votre temps
vous vous enviez les petits vieux qui
sont sur leur chaise face à la mer avec
un truc alors michel votre mémoire vous
tient compagnie et vous dites comme ça
j'ai des éruptions comme ces éruptions
volcaniques les éruptions de mémoire
dans le cerveau des éruptions chimiques
ou neuronale dans le magma mou de la
cervelle est alors dans ces éruptions
comme ça mémorielle vous revivez vos
amours vous revivez vos vos vingt ans
vous dit quelque chose de très
intéressant vous dites quand j'avais 20
ans j'étais j'aime et une femme
et c'était la première fois de ma vie où
quelqu'un comptait plus que moi même oui
c'est une vraie définition de l'amour
quoi quand on dit je veux mourir pour
toi c'est ça oui c'est c'était compte je
ne lui ai pas dit ouais je vais pas dit
mais j'ai pensé que je pourrais donner
ma vie pour elle et c'est la seule fois
j'ai honte de le dire parce que j'étais
mariée trois fois mais mais c'est la
seule fois où j'ai ressenti cela et
c'est parce que j'avais 20 ans à 30 ou
40 c'est déjà plus rare qu'on ait encore
des vous cherchez une cause pour
laquelle vous sacrifiez et c'était cette
femme oui alors ça c'est un peu ce que
clément rosset me répond il me dit oui
mais ça c'est bien ton côté au lieu
d'accepter le réel la vie telle qu'elle
est tu veux toujours trouver un double
c'est qu'ils t'aiment de clément rosset
c'est le réel et sur double et que
l'homme il est toujours à courir après
un double un fantôme qui n'existe pas et
ils disent et c'est ça ton côté
finalement c'est pas la vie que tu aimes
c'est un rêve de vie
je crois que c'est un de mes défenses et
juste mais ça c'est juste c'est oui oui
c'est qu'on ne peut pas atteint c'est
fini lui maintenant il est devenu sa rue
et ça beaucoup grâce à clément
ouais c'est clément rose emma la force
de le lire ça demande beaucoup de temps
et on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des tas de
gens qui ont gâché leur vie qui continue
à courir après les utopies chimères de
chimères alors dengue dansez dansez
éruption comme ça mémorielle il ya
l'amour on aime le dial sexe ou si vous
étiez un sacré bazar c'est vrai que
j'étais un peu un obsédé sexuel ou et
oui oui oui je m'en rends compte
aujourd'hui que je ne le suis plus
heureusement parce que être obsédé
sexuel à mon âge c'est sain c'est
dégueulasse un peu pervers pépère ouais
alors quand vous racontez votre vie
évidemment vous à une façon de la
raconter vous dites je vais de
désillusion en désillusion
j'étais un grand naïf et aujourd'hui je
suis un misanthrope vous dites même
aujourd'hui je suis aigri vous mais plus
voir les gens vous commençait même à
détester les hommes vous n'avez plus la
générosité que vous aviez à l'époque ça
doit être très douloureux à vivre ça non
oui parce que je m'en veux rejouer il ya
une usure qui se produit bon chez moi
elle s'est produit dans le corps avant
de se produire dans la tête
donc c'est vrai que ça passe par le
corps mais mais
douleur ça m'a écrit voilà mes paroles
s'envolent les écrits restent
francis bacon du service vous avez pensé
au suicide
et ça c'est assez joli pensé au suicide
oui j'aime flingue et façon le monde ne
mérite pas extra jusqu'au jour vous avez
des vrais problèmes de santé mais ça je
trouve ça génial cher que finalement
vous avez pensé au suicide jusqu'au jour
où j'ai eu peur de la mort ce qui est
extraordinaire
oui le jour où j'ai senti que bon ça
c'est un carnet de dans mon corps
effectivement je ne lui font pas jouer
avec ça et puis si vous voulez il ya
aussi scruté amusant de se dire qu'est
ce que je me soucie du suicide et la
juriste de brûler demain pour ça
semblait sérieuse difficile c'est bon
c'est très juste le suicide est
programmée samedi encore trois mois est
venu me faire un truc là ils m'ont fait
une anesthésie 7 et comme pour
chevènement je suis resté sur le billard
jeux va y rester un bon bouquin email
qui a répondu à des gens chez eux et
beaucoup
non mais c'est terrible avec plaque
parce que je sais qu'au fond il ya une
vraie joie dit heureusement sinon il
sera plus là mais par exemple vous
croyez la fin du monde à ses proches
vous dites l'humanité le pressent comme
les animaux qu'ils pressentent un
tremblement de terre est ce que michel
polac est-ce que vous confondez pas la
fin de vous on la fin de votre monde
avec la fin du monde change
c'est à dire que je pense après après 68
j'ai dit vraiment c'était une des
dernières sens que l'humanité un petit
peu se réveille échanges de voix comme
ça loupé que ça s'est révélé mon une
mascarade et
bah on va ensuite on va vers la fin du
monde et puis avec la pollution et tout
le bataclan
moi j'avoue que je vois pas comment s'en
sortira qu'en tira 8 milliards
d'habitants qui voudront avoir une
bagnole oms asphyxiera et on crèvera
mais pour dire qu'il ya des gens qui
mettent fin à leurs jours chez eux en ce
moment avec note d'espoir à moins que
les paroles s'envolent les écrits
restent
alors finalement quand on lit votre
bouquin attentivement un michel pas là
qu'on s'aperçoit que le drame de votre
vie c'est le destin de votre père qui
vous a quand même toujours travailler
votre père a été arrêté pendant la
guerre à 4 heures du matin il a fait
partie des premières rafles corps il
était sur la liste des anciens
combattants de 14-18 et votre père bon
était juif il a fait la guerre de 14-18
et il s'est dit pétain va me protéger
arnaque a fait la guerre de 14 18 il dit
pétain il était allé s'inscrire bêtement
sur la liste des anciens combattants y
croyait une liste envoyée à pétain pour
être protégés et là
les [ __ ] compris la liste et hop ils
ont arrêté tout le monde alors il ya un
mythe dans votre enfance dans votre
famille comme ça avec votre mère c'est
papa et en sibérie va revenir et c'était
une espèce de rêve ma mère se protéger
c'est comme si je vérifie les de l'opium
des gens venus et les russes les ont
libérés et puis les ans futur en sibérie
parce que c'est le bordel là bas et on
le croyait alors on s'est dit bah oui un
jour il est malin le welte un héros pour
moi revenir viollier trop malin il va
revenir lui échapper et puis un jour on
apprenait qu'il émarge il ya cinq six
ans on voyait un film à la télé sur le
train qui a emmené s'est déportée en 42
à auschwitz et qu' il y avait un
survivant qui racontait que dès le
lendemain matin on les a fait sortir du
bloc et on les a tuées à coups de bâtons
sont tombés les uns sur les autres et
après le crématorium et ça je ne vais
pas su pendant 50 ans - c'est peut-être
ça qui a fait de vous un asocial d'une
certaine façon ce que vous appelez un
boîtier d'un enfant sauvage
en tous les cas un homme contre un homme
incontrôlable oui non mais c'est sûr que
ma révolte et parce que là je suis
rentré dans la vie d'une mauvaise façon
et c'est là où avec clément rosset
renouer un dialogue intéressant parce
que lui n'a pas eu une enfance protégée
il n'a pas connu ce qui m'est arrivé
donc
il a une façon d'accepter la vie et le
monde que je j'ai essayé d'avoir c'est à
dire que oui il ya des moments je dis
oui il a raison c'est le soleil se
lèvera encore demain la vie est belle
qu'est-ce que je m'emmerde
et puis il ya un petit coin dans ma tête
qu'ils n'en n'ont que ça va pas faire de
france
j'accueille masquant fabienne nérac
[Musique]
bonsoir fabien de nérac bonsoir vous
êtes les pousses du cameraman français
frédéric nérac disparu en irak alors
qu'il travaillait pour la chaîne
britannique
haïti m alors les circonstances de sa
disparition le 22 mars 2003 près de
bassorah dans le sud de l'irak
l'équipe à laquelle appartenait votre
mari est pris sous les feux des forces
de la coalition probablement pensons des
marines américains le correspondant d'al
tienne terry lloyd et tué le cameraman
belge daniel demoustier et blessé et
parvient à s'échapper et frédéric nérac
votre époux et l'interprète libanais qui
s'appelle hussain osman sont portées
disparues voilà donc depuis vous avez
remuer ciel et terre
vous avez vu des autorités américaines
et autorités britanniques
les autorités françaises vous avez vu
colline powell qu'est ce qui vous a dit
colin powell quand même qu elle m'a
promis
de me donner les informations m'a fait
une promesse solennelle
il me reviendrait avec des informations
et aujourd'hui je n'ai toujours rien
rien de la part de colin powell
non alors il ya des embrouilles parce
que les américains disent que la carte
de presse de votre mari et puis celle
aussi du l'interprète libanais ont été
retrouvés par les britanniques dans un
local du parti baas
mais les britanniques démentent donc là
aussi pareil quoi s'est il n'y a pas de
pas de solution bah disons que les
britanniques ont démenti dans un premier
temps et maintenant maintenant disent
que effectivement c'est bien eux qui ont
trouvé les cartes de presse lors d'un
raid donc
on a la chaîne haïti n a pu voir ces
cartes de presse ce sont bien celles de
frédéric et de hossein
donc maintenant ce qu'on ce que moi je
demande c'est plus de précisions c'est à
dire quand avez vous trouvé sa carte de
presse ou
[Musique]
à quelle date et à quelle occasion
exactement alors le 19 mai il ya une
réunion à bruxelles une réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères et des
ministres de la défense des pays
européens
il y avait trente journalistes ce jour
là donc qu'ils ont posés à terre leurs
micros et leur caméra en signe de
solidarité avec vous et avec votre mari
frédéric nérac
vous avez vu le ministre britannique de
la défense
gough hoon lui il a refusé avare de
prendre la lettre que vous l'attendiez
oui c'était assez surprenant parce que
tous les ministres qui sont arrivés et
m'ont accueilli vraiment chaleureusement
en prenant ma lettre en lisant bon on va
en parler on va faire quelque chose et
on est passé devant moi m'a même pas
regarder alors que bon
il me connaît
et là il n'a pas pris la lettre que je
lui tendais alors papandréou le ministre
des affaires étrangères de la grèce lui
il a ouvert la session en lisant votre
votre demande quand même ça vous a mis
un peu de baume au coeur j'imagine là en
fait c'est un grand élan de solidarité
de la part de tous les journalistes et
techniciens de ce jour c'est que non
seulement ils ont posé leur caméra à
terre à l'arrivée des ministres mais
après pour le tour de table
ils ont deux nouveaux reposer leurs
caméras à terre empêchant donc
tout tout tout début de réunion et donc
le président de la
de la séance qui est donc la présidence
grecque s'est senti obligé de devoir
commencer la cession en parlant de la
disparition de frédéric dard vous ce que
vous ne pouvez pas ne pas dire on
comprend vous dites que ça prend du
temps c'est extrêmement difficile
peut-être parce que votre mari est
français et son interprète et libanais à
un moment donné j ai pensé et puis j'ai
quand même eu un entretien avec jeff
koons lundi en
en fin d'après midi on entretien privé
ou là j'ai clairement compris qu'en fait
c'était pas leur priorité que
leur priorité sur le terrain c'était une
autre enquête sur laquelle il était
engagé et il m'a dit qu'il n'avait pas
de suffisamment de moyens sur le terrain
pour rechercher recherché frédéric ce
qui est un petit peu aberrant parce que
bon quand on mène déjà une un peu
facilement mener une deuxième et puis
surtout l'équipe d'haïti yen à engager d
un commando spécial une équipe privée
qui a enquêté depuis le 30 mars
et nous nous avons plus d'informations
que les militaires britanniques
nous leur avons donné toutes nos
informations et notamment qu' il y a
neuf irakiens qui on arrête été arrêté
sur le site de l'incident qui sont des
prisonniers de guerre et on leur demande
depuis plus d'un mois d'aller interroger
ces prisonniers de guerre parce qu'ils
savent certainement ce qui a pu se
passer
qu'est ce qui a pu se passer fabia une
chose est sûre on sait maintenant de par
notre enquête toujours privé c'est que
la voiture de frédéric est du traducteur
a été arrêté avant les tirs a été arrêté
par les irakiens et il a été déplacé de
cette voiture
ils ont été tous les deux des places et
de cette voiture alors c'est tout ce
qu'on sait on ne sait pas s'ils ont été
emmenés par les irakiens au siège du
parti baas là où on a retrouvé les
cartes de presse et sa voiture
sa voiture identifié ytn enfin tv de
bien identifier tv ou bien s'ils les ont
même si ils ont été
tué sur place en fait on a on n'a pas de
précision à ce niveau là mais tous les
témoignages de il ya des journalistes
embarqués qui sont passé une heure après
l'incident qui ont pris des photos qui
ont voulu intervenir les américains les
en ont empêchés en leur disant si vous y
allez vous êtes sous naughty donc vous
prenez vos responsabilités
du coup ils sont pas allés mais dès
qu'ils sont sortis dehors
un b demain il nous ils nous ont
contactés ils ont dit voilà on a des
photos ce qu'on peut vous dire c'est
qu'il y avait une équipe militaire de
caméras qui filmaient donc ils nous ont
montré cette photo et ça a été un petit
peu cette photo qui a fait que coline
powell s'est senti obligé de devoir
ouvrir une enquête informelle sur le
terrain chirac et villepin ils ont fait
quoi pour vous monsieur chirac m'a reçu
tout de suite c'était au tout début de
sa disparition puisqu'il a disparu le
premier jour de la guerre il m'a reçu
tout de suite
en apportant son soutien mais ne pouvant
pas faire un chose étant donné la
position de la france lorsque immobile
m'a reçu maintenant monsieur de villepin
fait beaucoup plus c'est à dire qu'il
m'a reçu une fois je suis déjà allé
trois fois au cabinet après cela où nous
avons eu des réunions de travail donc
maintenant la position de monsieur de
villepin est beaucoup plus franche c'est
à dire que il
il demande impérativement aux anglais de
de me donner des informations
et si les anglais n'y vont pas ils
demandent à ce que les français puissent
y aller oui voilà vous aimez enfants
fabienne 2 que lâche 17-14 l'autre
mobiliser tous les trois oui absolument
ce qui est génial dans ces cas là c'est
de voir la force des femmes c'est super
mouche
[Applaudissements]
à bienne
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec les
moyens à nous pour vous aider continuer
à en parler
oui jusqu'à ce qu'on sache ce qui est
arrivé absolument
bon viendrait alors très bien vous nous
direz oui d'évolution des choses aussi
volontiers merci
[Applaudissements]
bien et maintenant
précis de la faune
[Musique]
le fonds bonsoir d'oublier un livre bien
écrit un livre qui dit quelque chose
chez flammarion et qui s'appelle une
fièvre impossible à négocier
[Musique]
alors c'était un livre dit vous qui n'a
pas été écrit pour être publiés il a été
écrit parce que vous n'aviez pas le
choix et un jour vous la portez ce livre
ce manuscrit à l'époque à plusieurs
éditeurs dont frédéric beigbeder qui
bosse chez flammarion désormais après
ses aventures sur canal en lui laissant
simplement votre prénom et votre numéro
de portable
ils vous rappellent le 2 janvier en vous
disant ça fait cinq minutes que je suis
chez flammarion jeu j'ai votre manuscrit
entre les mains ça m'intéresse ça parle
de ce qu'on appelait avant les autonome
et qu'aujourd'hui on n'appelle plus les
autonomes on appelle ça le black block
des groupes très radicaux ça parle des
squats
enfin des choses dont on parle jamais de
toute façon il dans les livres ni à la
télé et en plus c'est vu de ses vues de
l'intérieur c'est là que vous vous ou
participer à ces mouvements
altermondialistes anti globalisation et
si la première fois finalement que ça
s'exprime dans un livre à la fois de ne
pas trop stresser
assise à côté de pau là qu'il faut le
bourdon mai
va passer leur noël ce que je fais une
petite critique il n'a pas bien supporté
non c'est pas une fête et que je trouve
que c'est très grave ce qu'on vous dit
en fait manqué ce qu'il dit
vous avez dit un truc on entend assez
souvent que ce que vous décrivez comme
des casseurs à
ce que moi j'appelle pas vraiment je
n'appelle pas ça des casseurs mais bon
vous dit ouais ça aucun intérêt c'est
des flics
moi je dis que de dire que la colère
des gens dans un monde on est en train
de crever tous âges nous c'est des flics
c'est super grave parce que ce que vous
faites vous dévalorisez complètement la
colère des gens passent peut-être vous
en avez plus ça je sais pas et en plus
ce que vous faites ce que vous dites
faut pas bouger il faut rester assis
parce que finalement c'est ça hein vous
dites vous dites mais si vous dites sais
pas si c'est pas bien et moi je trouve
ça très très grave
fazul et c'est ce que j'avais dit ce
serait effectivement pourquoi j'ai
seulement dit ceci c'est que vous étiez
trop jeune pour vous rappeler qu'après
68 et bien chaque fois que la droite
voulait faire que les élections cassé
khelif les bras ils ont rien des flics
déguisés en casseurs pour casser le
rythme était trop jeune à l'époque a
besoin de l'équipe année et donc je dis
méfiez-vous de l'est marc cela il s'en
souvient et donc il ya toujours eu mêlés
à des casseurs innocents et qu'ils
voulaient faire ça pour des bouts raison
qu'il croyait bonne ddd des exploiteurs
flics et voilà et donc c'est toujours à
la limite possible aujourd'hui
oui c'est oui c'est possible qu'ils
aient des flics qui a toujours des flics
dans les manifs il ya des flics un peu
partout cela n'empêche pas le fait qu'il
faut bouger et que c'est ultra je dis
assez
foot le feu à des bagnoles ça intéresse
drôlement ya pas que ça t'es pas faux
que la fois des scooters secteur alors
on va parler du bouquin le ladakh
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune immigrée
roumagne s'appelle l'andra qu'à 26 ans
qui écrit des chansons et qui est violée
c'est le pitch
je fais qui est violée par un mec du du
showbiz est là pour détruire ce monde et
reconstruire le sien elle rejoint un
groupuscule donc un groupuscule anti
fasciste et alter mondialiste voilà ça
c'est de l'histoire du bouquin alors
vous quand vous étiez enfant vous viviez
un petit peu comme votre héroïne en
roumanie et vous raconter cette chose
très étonnante
c'est qu'à l'époque en roumanie à cause
des micros qui avait partout finalement
quand on quand on avait envie de dire
des choses interdites ou même de chanter
des choses interdites on se mettait dans
la salle de bain et on faisait couler le
robinet pour éviter que les micros capte
ce qu'ont raconté ou ce qu'on chantait
et robinet l'eau qui coule ça favoris
les micros alors votre héroïne et vous
d'ailleurs un petit peu le même destin
même si c'est pas un livre complètement
autobiographique vous découvrez un
moment paris la société de consommation
elle dit je voulais faire partie de ce
grand club où les filles j'adore cette
phrase où les filles ont des règles
bleus comme dans les pubs
c'est beau ce qui est extraordinaire
dans son bouquin c'est qu'elle arrive de
roumanie la détester évidemment le
régime de ceausescu et la dictature qui
régnait là-bas mais finalement la
société de consommation ne trouve pas
plus grâce aux yeux de votre héroïne
ou autre je dirai tout d'un coup elle
arrive dans un monde où la seule chose
qui compte c'est de fonctionner et quand
on fonctionne plus on vous jette à la
poubelle
c'est ce qui se passe tout le temps
d'ailleurs on jette des gens à la
poubelle tout le temps dès qu'ils
fonctionnent plus et
voilà tant qu'ils peuvent consommer sont
intéressants car ils consomment plus
alors effectivement elle arrive en
occident elle découvre cette société de
consommation et puis un jour elle
trébuche sur un corps
devant un grand magasin et c'est un sdf
avec une pancarte qui dit simplement en
fin de droits ça veut dire que on admet
d'emblée bon et des gens il faut qu'ils
crèvent par terre c'est super normal et
ça c'est une idée terrible si on
commence à y penser chercher
vous trouvez là que ça ne choque pas
c'est finalement mais je pense que on
est dans une course
enfin en tout cas on est obligé il faut
survivre il faut écraser son voisin faut
aller plus vite pour être plus speed
parce que sinon on va terminer par terre
et moi j'ai pas envie du fait villa et
je pense qu on est énormément à pas
vouloir vivre cette vie là et le livre
bien écrit pour ça je suis sûr qu'il ya
plein de gens qui pensent comme moi je
suis très banal quoi le truc c'est que
savait pas combien on était et mais
c'est pas possible de rêver d'un truc
comme ça
et demain j'ai pas envie d'être la race
des maîtres parce que ça impliquerait
que les autres sont décédés esclaves
c'est pas mon idée quoi alors comme vous
votre héroïne fait de la musique
la différence est que vous faites pas de
céder en fait juste des concerts vous
fait de l'électro balkanique
il faut connaître sa l'électro
balkanique elle en revanche pas du tout
ces appels de n'être homolka ni maison
jardin elle en revanche elle n accepte
tout à fait le jeu et elle fait un
disque avec une une boîte qui s'appelle
univers propre donc on a compris à qui
sait des références
et là elle rencontre un compositeur de
musique de film celui qui va la violer
celui que vous appelez dans le bouquin
l'homme insoupçonnable
parce qu'effectivement quand on le voit
il a des tennis blanches on voit à la
télé sur paris-première dites vous on
vous le nommez pas pour laisser aux
messages sa portée vous ne le vous ne
racontez pas le viol
simplement ce qu'on apprend c'est que
ces 25 minutes de viol ont détruit la
vie de de l'andra votre héroïne elle dit
il paraît que mon psychisme a explosé
dans un blanc déchirer comme dans john
où je suis décousu voilà oui je pense
que c'est aussi une des raisons pour moi
qui était important pour moi de ce livre
soit là parce que je fasse je me dis bon
pour moi c'est pas évident d'être là
par exemple ce soir mais je me dis mon
il ya sûrement des filles qui regarde ça
et là et qui ont vécu la même chose est
la pire des choses c'est l'isolément
c'est la solitude quand on est tout seul
on peut rien faire alors ce qui est
incroyable dans votre bouquin c'est que
dans ce squat ou lembras se réfugie le
squad saint sauveur il ya guy georges le
tueur de l'est parisien
mais qui est un mec sympa dit georges
habiter dans un squat et et comme
peut-être au dessus chez vous il ya un
serial killer c'est pas écrit sur le
front évidemment c'est une personne qui
était complètement insoupçonnable et
vous dites enfin l'héroïne dit je sais
maintenant que le viol n'a l'air de rien
mais c'est vrai qu'entre l'homme
insoupçonnable du show biz le
compositeur de musique de film qui a des
tennis blanches et guy georges qui
finalement se comporte d'une façon tout
à fait normale
le viol n'a l'air de rien c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a pas écrit violeur
effectivement est là pour éviter ça
chosification pour éviter la
chosification du monde
l'héroïne un peu comme vous l'avez fait
aussi lola rejoint les black blocks donc
et êtes attiré par une affiche qui dit
c'est une instrument extraordinaire la
résignation est un suicide quotidien on
dirait 122,68 oui oui mais c'est vrai
que bon il faut se méfier du mot
résignation ça peut être aussi une forme
de forme de sagesse et c'est toute
l'ambiguïté de la résignation et puis je
crois que surtout la révolte pur c'est
très beau c'est très romantique mais
malheureusement ça n'a jamais abouti à
rien ça permet de se se sauver à ses
propres yeux a envoyé je me suis révolté
les anarchy en foutu des bombes en 1900
ça n'a servi à rien ça a tué des gens ça
c'est rien les les
les terroristes ont foutu des bombes en
russie ça a amené finalement une
répression effroyable et ça n'a pas fait
avancer la révolte d'auxerre que toutes
les actions que fait que fait l'andra et
que fait le là enfin je veux dire peu
importe si ce taux biographiques ou pas
on s'en fout saint nicolas du chardonnet
versailles quand ils vont se battre
contre les militants anti ivg
il ya cette phrase avec laquelle je suis
pas du tout d'accord mais tant pis si
marie avait connu l'avortement
on n'aurait pas tous et emmerdements
le gign qui vide le squat tout ça vous
pensez que ça n'a pas d'importance ici
mais attention dans son squat il ya des
violents il ya des gars qui ont des
armes ce qui vous choque c'est plus
depuis le début depuis la conversation
ce qui vous choque c'est une vitre qui
tombe c'est une chose moi j'ai aucun jeu
vous êtes moins choqué par la mort des
gens vous savez vous êtes choqué par une
vitrine de nike qui tombe mais moi j'ai
aucun respect pour nike gamme et
mcdonald's jeu juste vous dire
nike il faut bosser des enfants de 7 ans
en indonésie
c'est ça qui compte c'est les gens moi
les choses j'ai du respect pour la vie
humaine j'ai pas une respect pour les
objets et donc je comprends pas vraiment
votre histoire de violence la violence
et les états qui la feront la violence
et la guerre c'est les bombes qui tuent
des gens s'élançant agir il faut agir
d'une façon intelligente pas aussi conne
manque ce mur en face à l'écossé un mcdo
c'est idiot
de même le démontage du mcdo de saint
louis s'est conclue et allez c'est pas
ça le problème
il ya un truc qui bouge chaque
absolument et c'est normal enfin se dire
qui choque l'héroïne puisqu'elle était
violée c'est une publicité de l'agencé
young rubicam au sujet d'aidés rocher
suchard et le slogan c'est quand vous
dites non on entend oui il c'est vrai
quand on a été violée ce slogan pour du
chocolat prend une autre signification
je pense qu'il ya c'est pas moi en mais
je pense qu'il ya peut-être beaucoup de
beaucoup de filles qui en voyant cette
affiche très marrante pour plein de gens
envie de pleurer et pour vendre des
objets faire pleurer des gens sur ça
c'est pas la peine
alors voilà donc vous raconter toute
l'action de ces groupuscules radicaux
alter mondialiste soutien aux indiens
zapatistes banderole sur l'opéra lors
d'un meeting de jean marie le pen c'est
là que le pen prend la parole d'un seul
coup sur la façade de l'opéra
il ya une banderole ce qui apparaît le
plus difficile pour votre héroïne dans
le bouquin c'est pas tenir tête aux
flics aux renseignements généraux au
front national ces de renaître après
après ce viol après cette éventration
pour vivre debout vivre debout c'est
tout respirez êtres vivants parce que on
va mourir et c'est pas un jeu vidéo
donc voilà j'ai pas envie de d'attendre
quelque chose qui arrive jamais michel
ça vous ne manque pas de ne plus avoir
cette espèce de rage
moi je donc franchement ça ne manque pas
à mon âge un monde quand on a une que
l'on préfère vide coucher que livre de
moux
[Musique]
aussi
cg
[Musique]
messieurs nous libérer merci voilà bah
oui c'est l'heure de coucher le pp 1
week ago moi allez voir j'ai embrassé
des mes deux principaux atouts pour le
pain voudrait tellement camille michel
mouillart
et maintenant
[Musique]
là
voici diziz la peste
[Musique]
bonsoir premier album poisson rouge
s'est vendu à 240 milles exemplaires et
le premier single je pète les plombs à
sa cent mille exemplaires
[Musique]
pas mal ouais c'est vachement bien votre
deuxième album s'appelle jeux de société
et le single s'appelle changer l an
j'étais
gr
m
ce score de 1 0
cinéma
tél
quand j'ai nouvel album à ce que je
découvre avec un pote à ma caisse
[Musique]
que j'accuse nous
il a fait
[Musique]
france 4 à vélo
l'insee
10 gige la pêche guez et album s'appelle
jeux de société
[Musique]
alors disease je suis gay ça veut dire
si heureux c'est rare dans le rap le
bonheur non à partir au mans je pense
qu'on a vendu des disques on vit de sa
musique on a commencé à toucher son rêve
on est heureux donc jamais faire est de
dire alors l'album jeux de société il ya
des chansons évidemment il ya dix-neuf
titres
et puis il ya des intermèdes comme ça
par dieudonné qui sont super drôle au
milieu comme ça entre les chansons
alors l'idée des jeux de société c'est
de parler du social d'une façon ludique
1 2 justement c'est un peu ce qui vous
caractérisent
vous êtes influencé par ntm par
ministère amer mais pour vous le vrai
record c'est pas nique la police mais en
fait parler des livres d'histoire qui
raconte pas la vérité quoi et vous à une
chanson des gars qui s'appelle cours
d'histoire ce cas une certaine démagogie
qui s'est installée dans le rap on
critique toujours la police l'êta et
tout mais je pense que nous aussi on a
notre lot de défauts et faut savoir en
parler aussi
ouais alors vous parlez également d'isis
du rôle de la télé dans la montée de
l'insécurité enfants de la vue l'année
dernière avant les élections
présidentielles
oui c'est quelque chose qui vous va à
vrai dire le 21 avril contrairement à
beaucoup moi ça m'a pas trop étonné en
fait dans le sens où depuis tellement
longtemps montereau les choses en
épingle il ya trop de clichés trop de et
c'est normal que les gens aient peur en
fait et quand on a vu le matraquage qui
a eu avant les élections papy voise la
veille des élections
ouais c'est malheureux mal au coeur en
voyant lui qui s'était fait brûler sa
maison et c'est clair la ferme à sa
cellule en boucle en boucle j'ai eu très
très mal au coeur en voyant sincèrement
et peut-être que si j'avais été je vais
pas dire que c'est intelligent mais si
j'avais été beaucoup moins intelligent
et que j'avais été un français vivant je
sais pas où vous aurez peut-être voter
pour le front national parce qu' on
aurait monté ça dans ma tête
alors les musulmans disent musulmans
pratiquants vous dites que vous n'êtes
plus modéré qu'au début - - et les vous
n'avez pas le zèle du néophyte alors
évidemment vous buvez pas d'alcool vous
fumez pas tigana il fait de prière cinq
fois par jour
gc oui j'essaye mais vous êtes voilà
vous êtes moins dedans qu'à une époque
où on ne dit jamais non plus été battu
parce que je pense que quand on
quand on découvre pas quand on découvre
mais quand on a la maturité d'essayer de
comprendre la foi ou une religion
qu'elle soit chrétienne ou juive ou
musulmane on veut tout apprendre mais
parce que c'est tellement un bon en fait
qu'on veut tout apprendre et c'est d'en
faire trop et et après en grandissant on
voit qu'après tout on n'est pas un
prophète et qu' on n'est qu'un être
humain et que
c'est des choses écrites et divinement
bien et que c'est à nous de les accepter
avec ce que l'on est en fête
alors j'ai quand même déclaré dans
tracklist une phrase assez assez dur
vous expliquer je préfère perdre mes
enfants plutôt que de perdre la foi ces
graphes c'est une religion c'est une
vision très personnelle en fait et ce
que je voulais dire c'est que moi ma foi
elle n'est pas personnel c'est que quand
je prie je pense à l'humanité je pense à
à tout ce qui est de bon dans l'être
humain est sûre c'est sur cette ville a
donc je pense que c'est une chose
tellement importante et si la foi des
gens qui prétendent avoir la foi était
plus altruiste et ben le monde irait
beaucoup mieux en fait l'île c'est pour
ça que cette fois qui est si importante
pour moi qui me fait que j'aime
l'humain c'est vraiment une chose qui
est très très très importante pour moi
voilà mais je pense sincèrement que le
fait de prier dans ma conception des
choses
ça peut changer les choses c'est des
enfants j'ai un enfant
j'espère en avoir plein d'autres vous
avez des copains qui barrent dans
l'islamisme radical
10 sincèrement non parce que ce serait
pas des copains donc alors au sujet de
l'irak vous citer cette phrase de
demande est là pour l'apartheid
ils n'ont rien fait mais pour un petit
pays comme l'irak qui font tout ça y est
ce qu'il ya beaucoup de pétrole
il ya beaucoup d'un mais le truc qui me
sidère c'est que
l'ira qui avait enfin je veux dire c'est
beaucoup d'histoires fait et en premier
ce qu'ils ont reconstruit c'est la
tenais tout ça mais je crois qu'ils ont
détruit le musée le musée ils montrent
pas reconstruit alors que je sais pas
c'est là je crois que c'est là bas qu'on
a inventé l'écriture des choses que je
disais dominique wolton ici juste les
américains arrivent pas à comprendre
c'est qu'un paysan irakien dans son
champ il ya 5000 ans d'histoire dans la
tête mais là il ya une chose qu'on a du
mal à comprendre nous c'est la vision de
la femme dans l'islam
mais est-ce que c'est pas l'image où les
choses qu'on met toujours en exergue
justement dans les médias et on nous
montre toujours ce côté là on entre
toujours des femmes qui sont même pas
voilée qui sont comme les critères comme
les ça veut dire comme les momies quoi
moi j'ai une femme elle n'est pas comme
une momie parce que j'ai confiance en
aide et je me dis que c'est doit se
préserver à la fois c'est par rapport à
dieu je ne suis pas dieu n'est pas à lui
de faim moi c'est ma vision des choses
en tout cas et j'estime qu'elle a un
cerveau elle est assez intelligente pour
se respecter
mais c'est ma vision des choses elle est
musulmane votre femme sénégalaise oui ça
vous est métisse vous mais vous avez
épousé une sénégalaise vous avez pu
épouser une une française les françaises
vous avez choisi l'autre côté non j'ai
besoin je vais beaucoup le sénégal
oui mais en fait c'est normal c'est à
dire que j'ai grandi en france et donc
ce côté là le côté africain m'a beaucoup
manqué ouais donc quand j'y suis allé
j'ai pour ça que je comprends très bien
de ce que raconte quand je vois
l'afrique dans l'état où elle est je
suis revenu j'étais un pro black megan
en quoi c'est à dire que c'est la
poubelle faut le savoir c'est la
poubelle de l'occident
les voitures elles sont complètement
mais a quand même 7 cette force ses
vertus c'est pour raconter que vous êtes
parti au sénégal est arrivé en avion et
le lendemain matin
voilà vous avez marcher dans le sable
parce qu'elle ait pu minutes goudronnée
j'ai été réveillé par la léchère
par le cher et c'est un choc pour vous
un choc et je suis sorti j'ai vu un
palmier
mais c'était féerique sincèrement
l'autre cas ce qui est sûr c'est que j'y
vais très souvent et je veux que mes
enfants et à ypres et souvent et
j'invite tous les gens au lieu d'aller
en vacances en thaïlande aller en
afrique ou bien on va voir les endroits
où tu veux aller les endroits où tu veux
pas aller on va faire une interview
j'y vais j'y vais pas alors 10 chanter
pour l'arbre de noël de l'elysée tivat
il va pas à l'elysée non l'arbre de noël
chez une famille
ouais c'est pas pour le moment là la
villa de nice people tu y vas où tu vas
pas si c'est en direct
j'y vais et je dis ça je dis non c'est
sûrement pour ça c'est rien sur sa copie
si j'y vais et que c'est en direct jeudi
des messages de fouet au hiv et y va
elle suivait de la laurence sert de
reproposer à toi tu vas y aller non
et pourtant c'est super bien rac et non
1 c'est vrai il est bien là et après on
continue j'y vais j'y vais pas oh put
avec des potes qui va ou ne va pas non
plus maintenant
peut-être quand j'étais jeune si jamais
allé mais peut-être que j'étais moi
recevoir une victoire de la musique des
mains de patrick fiori tu y vas outil va
pas ben oui pour une tentative ah ben
oui pourquoi pas boire un coup avec
sarkozy thiva outil va pas un oui comme
ça on va discuter on va voir bien sûr un
peu je vais défendre les miens qui me
regarder tout ça bien sûr chez mireille
dumas pour raconter tes malheurs tu y
vas où tu vas pas raconter mes malheurs
me faire de la promo et tout cela si le
pen es président tu prend le maquis où
tu y vas pas à je prend le maquis direct
chez ardisson tivaoune tu vas pas bien
sûr a pas pourquoi tu y vas parce que on
va dire que je laisse mes non mais parce
que je trouve que c'est une émission
justement qui est intéressante parce
qu'on invite des gens d'horizons sociaux
différents
culturellement différentes qui peuvent
venir donner leur point de vue est que
ya pas de démagogie et c'est ce que
j'apprécie le plus dans les filets
il
j'étais
suite
et maintenant antisociales
social
ouais si bernie bonvoisin
[Musique]
soir dernier
bonsoir axa vient alors bernie bonvoisin
vous êtes musicien parolier chanteur
scénariste réalisateur et désormais
écrivain voilà alors on vous a connu
effectivement leader de de trust avec
antisocial 13 c'était le seul vrai
groupe de hard français 1 tu te souviens
de sa web bien sûr que ces militants
maîtresse cgr espèce d'ovni comme ça
dans la france giscardienne alors à
l'époque on peut dire à ceux qui
n'étaient pas là que j'adore téléphone
c'était un peu les beatles et et trace
se perd un peu les stones si on veut
j'en veux comparer le voilà alors à
l'époque que vous étiez obligés de faire
des concerts parce que vous étiez
tricard à la radio et la télé
bon il est pas de clip outre l puisqu'à
l'époque on allait au luxembourg faire
faire faire des clips sur un plateau un
est donc le seul moyen qu'on avait deux
de se faire connaître de ce contrôle ans
c'est de faire des concerts ouais on
avait un album on se fait jeter
donc on a joué c'était pas évident
maintenant à maintenant la rébellion
tout ça c'est beaucoup plus facilement
acceptée à l'époque c'était giscard faut
se souvenir de ce qu'était la france à
l'époque
alors il est des tubes haut et
antisociales police police milices
l'esprit mesrine bosser moniteur est
ainsi bien entendu que c'était génial
non mais c'est vrai et des morceaux
comme ça qu'ils sont là on s'est croisé
à cognac avec bernie et je lui disais je
passais fut le sien mais que quand je
faisais un peu de rock au lycée j'avais
à bâle et de berne et moi j'avais se
trouve sur la ceinture du maton et et or
chez les voisins
les sens
je suis
[Musique]
voilà les gens lui devenu ton face lors
ouais on arrive aux oiseaux alors
tentons désespoir il reste un espoir est
de voir les jambes à taza et moi bah tu
as récemment c'est moi qui écrit les
paroles
alors voilà donc gardez vos voisins
c'était des trucs très très très engagé
un peu comme ntm aujourd'hui ou ministre
amar c'est vrai que c'était des choses
comme ça très cool et à une écoute il y
avait déjà une coupe du monde
ouais et vous disiez que si vous n'aviez
pas fait trust vous seriez étaient tous
en taule
c'était vraiment une façon de canaliser
là on venait tous deux cités sérieux
enfin je veux dire déjà les sites
étaient enfin puis il n'y avait pas et
pas la dot com est aujourd'hui mais ces
choses là mais c'était d'autres y avait
d'autres préoccupations quoi mais c'est
vrai qu'on avait tous des chemins comme
ça un peu
hasard de la musique nous a canalisé
dans un truc alors après trust aspic et
parce que vous aviez donné votre parole
un patron de maison de disques et quand
on vous a proposé une autre maison de
disette tenu bon ensuite le cinéma est
acteur d'abord dans la haine de
kassovitz et puis réalisateur dans les
démons de jésus les grandes bouches et
blanches blanche qui a fait sept cent
mille entrées d'amener cieux et qui est
vendu dans le monde entier ça c'est un
vrai succès moi j'adore rochefort en
costumes d'époque qui dit je suis en
pleine descente c'est vrai qu'à un
moment si tu veux on comprend pourquoi
ça s'appelle blanche voilà alors il ya
eu le rock est aussi née en septembre il
y aura le théâtre bernie 1
c'est un homme protéiforme derniers bons
voisins et en attendant il ya un livre
avec un titre magnifique
vous êtes fait de peine étrange très
très bon outil de d'un liban voisin
c'est publié chez flammarion
[Musique]
arriva le badge que j'avais s'arrête
alors c'est un vide de 60 pages c'est
une histoire d'amour
l'histoire d'un homme qui se retourne
sur une aventure amoureuse avec une
femme mariée
une femme de 1 une femme deux essais
c'est surtout tirer une réflexion sur le
silence amoureux voilà grâce une femme
deux qu'une femme acheter un canard et
riche dire ça elle a de l'argent et tout
ce qu'on peut acheter avec et surtout un
mari dit vous vous formiez dites-vous un
couple ou plus précisément une façade on
consent motif assez mystérieux à ses
secrets et c'est ce qui en fait le
charme d'ailleurs il ya ma description
abusive non non non pas de toute façon
ce n'était pas le but puisque encore une
fois c'est une il ya tout un tas de deux
de ces raids de choses qui ont qui ont
amené l'écriture de ça mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des schémas comme ça de jean jé
entre guillemets acheter qui vivent des
vies qui ne sont pas les leurs moi je
pars du principe que l'essentiel de la
vie c'est d'être à sa place le sentir à
sa place et
on peut avoir des personnes comme ça qui
se vendent sont pas la leur mais qu'il
accepte ouais alors cette femme est
belle un style européenne de l'ess ou
parler de de fêlure dans son regard
félin s'est en plus évidemment très très
bien écrit et alors on comprend tout ça
est très discret on comprend que le sexe
entre eux et est une apothéose
mais s'est traduit dans les mots de
façon très discrète vite à la moindre
occasion ans viol c'est vrai oui parce
que c'est là le manque un
le manque la tente et c'est vrai qu'une
progression dans le dans le désir est
que cette progression est toujours
agréable et donc ce sentiment d'attenté
plutôt bons à 6 malheureusement
l'histoire est assez linéaire
ces cinq à sept sont assez répétitif et
un jour elle elle disparaît alors
justement le là on a affaire aux deux
silence c'est à dire que au départ ça
peut me rends compte géré basiquement
humaine ce que sont les gens ce que
peuvent être une femme un homme qui se
rend compte qu'ils posent ce pour quoi
vous appréciez cette relation peu après
passer une relation amoureuse et là dans
le cadre du récit la relation amoureuse
s'arrête avec toujours l'espoir de
conserver de préserver la relation
humaine mais même y compris la relation
humaine est balayé
émise en l'air couet elle vous aimez ou
c'était qu'une passade sexuelle parce
que c'est terrible pour un mec
aventureront jeu peut-être que en aucun
cas on n'est qu'un god vivant pour les
gonzesses
non mais là je vous vendu mais non
encore une fois c'est
ça peut arriver tout ça est construit
quoi ça schéma onirique heures
voilà merci bernie bonvoisin j'ai poussé
lui merci dans la la fin je me saluer
à bientôt
oui
et maintenant
m
les
j'accueille basile de coqs et frigide
barjot
[Musique]
l iphone
basile de koch est frigide barjot
mesdames messieurs voilà alors voilà
donc vous êtes hinault vous êtes basile
et frigide un petit peu les laitiers ou
tce ce coup du groupe d'intervention
culturelle jalons oui nous sommes
pasticheur du roi depuis seize ans après
alors entre autres activités on vous
accorde la publication de pastiche de
journaux et de et de magazines vous avez
fait le monstre vous avez fait
l'aberration franche démence le loup
garou magazine le cafard acharné voirie
pour imhof
voilà est aujourd'hui fier entrevue
voilà dont le slogan est cher ce que
vous allez là toutes les conneries sont
bonnes à dire mesdames messieurs merci
bravo
[Musique]
c'est énorme c'est énorme coussin
c'est tom pouce à quelqu'un qui a droit
ou comme ça amélie le regard de regarder
melide
[Musique]
oui
dans from our on peut avoir mais leur
promo ce mois ci à 99 ans 99 jeudi noir
alors donc j'ai fait était évidemment
votre journée avec beaucoup d'intérêt
que je vais pas vous savez c'est un
journal que j'ai inventé en 92 n'a pas
inventé n'inventait entrevue et ensuite
trois ans après c'est devenu tellement
tragique que je me suis barré en courant
en revendant mais en revendant mais
tarde alors il ya mehdi tous déjà
personne si c'est le côté entrevue très
militante
personne ne nous empêchera jamais de
dire les vérités toute nue donc là déjà
dès le départ c'est un engagement
contient tout au long du journal il ya
que du vrai comme dans le modèle livré
nu ouais ah oui et du non forcément la
vérité toute nue c'est à dire que
parfois nous nous trouvons dans
l'obligation quand nous découvrons des
scandales comme la sphère des camps de
rééducation pour homosexuels en
kalmoukie vous obligé de montrer ces
images même si elles sont terribles et
pire il ya un truc qui est génial zoom
zoom mon garçon c'est une interview
exclusive de steve mcqueen
j'ai eu un mal fou à luffy entrevue à
retrouver voilà c'est notre envoyé
spécial au funérarium de boston qui l a
rencontrée dans devant une bonne bière
il ya aussi une prise de position contre
l'overdose de sexe à la télévision je
crois que c'est assez bizarre hawaii
pacifique celle-ci ceux qui s'insurgent
parce que c'est plus possible tout à
fait en a trop il ya une enquête sur le
business de la des pierres très
intéressant laon c'est vrai qu'il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont quitte
à choquer c'était en fait une
multinationale comme les autres
hôtellerie restauration rapide
stylisme événementiel
nous nous disons c'est une connerie
comme une autre mais elle est vraie on a
dit et puis à une pub qui est formidable
[Musique]
la réconciliation non n'exagérons rien
quand même
le plus incroyable c'est là deux mondes
de saisie de la direction du journal la
fin du vrai journal entrevue un grand
moment
comment peuvent-ils demander là la
saisie d'une parodie ça s'est jamais vu
ça non faussée solaire fois que ça nous
arrive ça ressemble un peu à la censure
préalable de charles 10 et oui à projet
depuis je sais ton ami louis philippe
est ce ça commence à lui si nous
regardent et en fait ce procédé est
étonnant on à en être le dernier jour du
bouclage vendredi dernier ouais quand
soudain une huissière sonne et nous
apporte une sommation de ne pas faire en
tant que parent est ce on est toujours
ravi mais en l'occurrence il s'agissait
de ne pas faire de parodies d'entrevue
aura déterminé
alors donc je lui ai dit qu'elle pouvait
se la mettre français et qu' il sera
répondu à cette lettre d'avocat par une
lettre d'avocat
voilà est en réalité il se trouve que le
président pons sont prises mende
entrevue oui puisque c'est lui chercher
à travers cette chose cette censure
préalable et la saisie de notre journal
il voulait laisser le terrain libre pour
la propre auto parodie officiel qu'il va
sortir ici il a entre eux mais ils ont
fait une parodie d'entrevue eux-mêmes
oui alors ça aussi c'est une nouveauté
il ya sa belle comment québec comment ça
s'appelle entre q paraît-il pas mal
il ya du boulot vole quand même il ya du
boulot alors maintenant le lien je pense
que
que le meilleur gagne ouais
[Musique]
alors benzine la question qui tue vous
travaillez à voici vous occuper du
people à voici comment peut-on attaqué
un journal de 2 comme entrevue quand on
bosse dans un journal de com voici
moi j'ai fais personnellement tout en
travaillant sur la page night club et
j'ai fait en même temps alors que
j'étais dans les lieux et salariés une
parodie de voici qui s'appelait voirie
ouais ce qui a un vague rapport donc
avec le caniveau et ils ont manifesté
suffisamment de distanciation
brechtienne pour ne pas me virer
ni même faire de procès et pourtant il
n'avait eu aucun contrôle aucun moment
sur la copie mais peut-être ont-ils eu
peur du ridicule
sriw et le cas apparemment vous êtes sûr
pensons et d'entrevues tu me l'enlève de
la beaucoup sa belle-fille entrevue
c'est dans tous les kiosques
enfin ce recueil ce soir il est
spécialement de vision j'ai un petit
message tiré si tu permets vendredi 6
juin il faut annoncer qu au zénith de
paris un concert de soutien pour le
mouvement ni [ __ ] ni soumises
il y aura golman y aura cet [ __ ] de
marc lavoine tant pis sera là il y aura
je plaisante bien sûr y aura faut dès
lors à l'âme un haricot macias et les
rita mitsouko
c'est le 6 juin au zénith et la recette
sera reversée au mouvement en faveur des
femmes victimes des violences des lieux
de violence dans les cités voilà c'est
quand c'est le 6 juin
vendredi jean leucémie merci non aux
pinceaux blancs intel ce soir un
blindtest mondovision révision oblige
aux platines j'appelle masia philippe
corti
j'appelle l'axé poste
oui
je les aurai qu'au début du plan thèse
il ya un jingle spring il ya la boule
qui descend didier
dans le câble abs mondovision alors je
vous avertis réponse est mort parce que
vous êtes trop fort avec non non non non
c'est grâce à mes gardes ta meuf des
gentils sur la garde
attention attention attention
philippe
[Musique]
à damas
j'espère échos
[Musique]
oui
jean marc ayrault
tensions continues je veux la tablette
se sont tous les pays du monde
philippe
serge ça je veux rappeler jacques
m
soit
oui moi
[Applaudissements]
la tension dans son film
[Musique]
migaud
[Applaudissements]
yahoo
[Musique]
magic system un point pour l'équipe de
cadets et droit
[Applaudissements]
ces règles
attention on finit par l'interprète
[Applaudissements]
actuellement
oui
il a notamment écrit maman encore là pas
trouvés ici c'est déjà un fils il a les
boules c'est même bien mais ça fait
comme gainsbourg il m'a piqué trois fois
gainsbourg fils de p j'ai rien contre sa
maman
attention publique
[Musique]
le point voilà
mode anti souffert
ce canton
la sq voilà le point bas à l'équipe de
cannes et ça fait vingt deux heureux et
3 pour eux c'est sage et l'équipe qui
porte mon anti souffle à jeter perdre
sur la presse ça joue pas attention si
j'avais son badge que j'étais petit
attention dit il
je te pour vous aussi allez je peux pas
assister à ça vient ici ça va être trop
fort on vient là la scala franchement
deux poupées pour kader mais ça c'est un
petit peu déplacé attention attention
philippe ménard au nom de l'ida moscou
[Applaudissements]
le mama
c'est normal
la parole le peuple ou sans doute
reconnaît catherine morin qui a toujours
raison
d'icade est vraiment catherine atlus
soirée merci
voilà très bien attention j'ai mangé à
jeudi j'ai dit j'ai dit jeudi un indice
là à jeudi un indice mère basque finit
plus
[Applaudissements]
les majors dans votre film bien j'ai
mangé désagréger manger des abeilles
mais j'ai pas mal non alors quatre pour
vous ça remonte et 5 pour l'équipe de
visite à fès
[Applaudissements]
attention
attention attention qu'on dit qu'il
avait du monde à jouer mais démenti rama
yade
on ne va pas
alors
[Musique]
serge replay
mais la contestation la
le meilleur
bac 4 mchf m
en maintenant les gens arrivant nous
arrivons à mi étape puisque c'est la fin
du para et keith donc en par équipes
c'est l'équipe donc de disiz la peste
disons un risque barjots basile de coqs
cristina marocco basque actionnaires
maintenant on passe au chacun pour ça
loc
donc là évidemment d'ailleurs plus
rapide il ya plus de d'amitié qui lient
d'amitié a plus rien y'a plus rien c'est
chacun pour sa gueule on nous chasse et
tu ton voisin tu ton voisin
[Musique]
m
oui
des manches et ma femme on doit arrêter
comme débranché
comment tu peux reconnaître actionner
mélina malheureusement pas ya anguille
sous roche
je suis sûr que je garde tout habitat
battant sur patins bon attention
attention philip earl jones ou qu'ils
font
[Applaudissements]
l'escem
une polar en une pour pascal célèbres
pionniers play là-dessus peut-être c'est
ma tournée je voulu afin qu'un sergent
il peut alors s'étendre
vient d'enfoncer
regarde pas forcément violence
[Applaudissements]
oui mon ami pascal sellem mon ami marc
leprat bravo
le revoir est-ce qu'on peut le revoir
pour le plaisir
d'accord
[Musique]
regarde pas forcément attention
tu as maintenant le number 1 mondiaux et
la route
un petit dernier pour la haute-vienne
dernier
maintenant maintenant dans quels impôts
lors un pont pascal on pince oméga banco
mesdames messieurs attention le méga
banque ou ses skis avant d'ultrabook
khadraoui attention lemay gabon co
attention à aa
[Musique]
non je sais qu'il s'est joint à coeur
en ces temps et sa peine oui
d'habitude première
oui bonsoir oui madame
[Musique]
je suis là
tha
j'étais
là c'est ultra dur j'ai vu qu'il trouve
sa genèse les pieds
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même si fois
or non belges à billets
bravo petit zizi le gagnant est celui
d'un soir avec sept titres mais désiré
je suis né
giguère
je suis fière
attention à pas
allez j'en ai vu ouais
la chaîne ne sait
ok je
julia d'heure
isabelle studio lasteyras jacques
besseghir
roissy
terroriste sécher
laffont 4
épreuve et la rose 2 et lartigau avec
kad et olivier pierre darmon jean-paul
rault saluant le 4 juin mesdames
viadeo landes
samedi
rocco le single clap elle appelle moi je
vais t'appeler
c'est le 27 mai que ça sort michel
beaulac le bouquin s'appelle franchise
postale
gd
on le sait
de prendre la vienne nérac qui cherche
on arrive et qu'on va
arnaud clément le bouquin s'appelle tu
as une botte et
les lingots gens et c'est publié mon
gosse
lola lafon chez flammarion une fièvre
possible à négoce
le vioxx la paix
je souhaitais et le soutien de rappel je
suis dell services
là j'ai flammarion vous êtes fait le pen
30 avocats 13
non 2
et plus juste par joe vient
voilà en vendant du lait viol reporters
sans frontières
les rations photos de stars le principe
est simple
les photos
l'aube est élevé
en gros aux enchères hier genre etc
importance
au contraire voilà les personnalités
participantes cette semaine son lambert
wilson
m
renvoi et rendez vous
attention rendez-vous dans quinze jours
la semaine prochaine c'est guillaume
durand
mon frère
[Musique]
m
genève
[Musique]
il est à noter